a veteran worker of the SCP Foundation
sits at his terminal performing one of
the most critical tasks in the entire
organization creating a file for an as
yet undescribed SCP but there's
something terribly wrong his eyes are
glazed over his mouth hangs open is this
a zombie or a trained Foundation
researcher what is going on like any
large International Organization it
takes more than just the exciting action
filled jobs to keep the wheels ret
turning at the SCP Foundation sure the
head researchers guards mobile task
force soldiers and members of the 05
command get all the praise but a legion
of number crunchers cleaners and paper
pushers are equally important one such
person was archist Walter Banbridge who
had been tasked with digitizing some of
the older records that the foundation
had on file it was when he was
innocently recording the details on SCP
050 through
060 that a first first came under the
strange and startling effects of SCP
055 but the most peculiar part as with
all incidents of SCP 055 anomalous
effects taking hold is that Walter had
no idea any of it was happening in his
new digitized filing system he first
took note of SCP 053 uclid class also
known as the young girl this anomaly was
a seemingly normal human female child
who provoked homicidal Insanity in those
directly exposed to her then SCP 054
safe class a non-aggressive humanoid
female made entirely of as well as
biologically and chemically identical to
regular Spring Water next SCP 056 uclid
Class A being that changes form to suit
its environment but only when all
observers lose focus of it and then SCP
057 safe class an underground chamber
that crushes the humans who walk within
it was at this point that Walter
received a concerned message from one of
his superiors at site 19 Mr kovat the
message praised the thorough
digitization of the other anomalies
records but was confused about why
Walter had left out any mention of SCP
055 immediately Walter was embarrassed
how could he have forgotten SCP
055 that iconic anomaly known for well
he couldn't quite say off the top of his
head but he'd be sure to look into it a
quick trip to the site 19 archive showed
him that there was actually quite a
hefty file on the nature of SCP
055 which must have been the result of a
huge number of studies what struck him
as strange was that all the files were
filled out in pen rather than being
typed up like a traditional file the
majority of these notes were written in
shorthand too as though they were
frantically taken during the tests
themselves on extremely short notice
there weren't even any redactions Walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after writing in an almost
trans-like State he looked back on his
work to see that he had written an entry
on SCP
058 a giant evil Bine heart with insect
legs and a scorpion Stinger strange he
thought that's when Walter got a call
from Mr kovat on his foundation issue
phone and he didn't sound happy he'd
given Walter Direct instructions to go
back and digitize the files on
055 and instead he'd been working on 058
what was the meaning of This Walter was
typically an extremely loyal and
diligent employee but the verbal barrage
from his supervisor had him considering
talking back just this once and hoping
it didn't get him demoted to d-class and
thrown into 682s Acid Bath for playtime
Walter G picked up some courage and
interrupted Mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what what SCP 055
actually was the line went silent for a
moment then his supervisor spoke again
this time with less confidence uh of
course I can tell you about SCP
055 it's a classic one of the first 100
how could you forget it's uh or you know
it's I think it's the one with um
another long pause as Mr kovat seemed to
search for the words but instead just
trailed off into silence knowing that
some of the anomalies on file were
dangerous mimetic hazards Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have
accidentally killed his boss by getting
him to think too hard about SCP
055 he asked if Mr kovat was okay and
finally got a reply I'm sorry I seem to
have zoned out for a second there what
were we talking about again but this
time it was Walter who couldn't answer
he had no idea at all what the two of
them were discussing just moments ago he
felt disoriented and kind of sick like
they'd taken some low-level amnestics Mr
kovat told Walter to get back to his
filing duties and they'd speak later
Walter then checked the messages he'd
received from Mr kovat earlier and there
it was PL as day you miss
055 go back and digitize that before
proceeding Mr K but Walter had never
even heard of an SCP 055 if such an
anomaly even existed what was going on
here
in that moment Walter realized he was
dealing with something much Stranger
Than Just a standard digitization job
after all how could he properly complete
his duties if SCP 055 seemed to be
impossible to speak write or even think
about unless you were directly observing
it at that moment Walter had to know and
ask around the entirety of site 19 to
find the answers if he had to sadly for
Walter he was about to embark on a much
more challenging task than he could have
ever imagined to paraphrase a supposed
quote from Socrates all I know is that I
know nothing and that's also about the
extent of the knowledge we have on SCP
055 also known as the anti-em and the
self- keeping secret what does it look
like when and how was it obtained by the
foundation what are its anomalous
abilities is this thing dangerous we may
never know because the only anomalous
ability of SCP 055 that we're aware of
is the fact that nobody is capable of
retaining any information about it it's
crucial to note that whatever 055 is it
isn't invisible or
Indescribable Foundation Personnel are
perfectly capable of entering its
containment chamber and observing it
without incident but mere minutes after
leaving the chamber any memories of the
particulars of 055 seem to spontaneously
erase themselves hence the self- keeping
secret but this didn't deter Walter
perhaps his greatest Advantage was that
he didn't know enough about the thing he
was investigating to know how futile his
mission was he wanted to know the
unknowable and a pesky issue like
impossibility wouldn't stop him he'd get
to whoever he needed to at site 19 to
get the answers he needed of course most
people had no knowledge of the
mysterious anomaly the common response
he got back from his colleagues was 055
do we even have a 055 well the realiz
ation of sudden memory loss or the
realization of 055 existence has been
known to cause momentary stress there
are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from 055 is anomalous
abilities it's a fleeting idea in its
purest form like forgetting why you
walked into a room 055 could be the most
harmless object on the foundation's
roster or the most deadly either way we
just don't know at times Walter worried
he was going insane 055 and everything
related to it was gaslighting him was
055 even real the one thing that proved
to him that 055 must have existed is
that its containment chamber existed
according to the official records kept
by the foundation on the site 19
containment facilities 055 is kept in a
5x5 by 2.5 M Square Room constructed of
50 ft thick cement with a faraday cage
surrounding the cement walls the report
continues that access is via a heavy
containment door measuring 2x 2.5 M
constructed on bearings to ensure door
closes and locks automatically unless
held open deliberately 055 cell is one
of the few to have no posted security
guards and any Personnel working on
other scps in the area are ordered to
remain at least 50 ft from the geometric
Center of 055 cell where the anomaly
itself is kept when he tried to explore
further why the cell was constructed in
this manner he found that surprise
surprise nobody knew 055 was an anomaly
whose containment requirements were so
mysterious that it automatically netted
itself a ker class designation after all
how can you properly contain something
you can't even hope to comprehend there
were plenty of rumors about the true
nature of
055 some of the more conspiratorial
Minds at site 19 theorize that 55 was
actually an autonomous or remotely
controlled spy inserted into the site to
observe Foundation operations or even
Humanity as a whole if you're on the
more paranoid end of the psychological
Spectrum this Theory makes total sense
an anomaly that's physically impossible
to remember even when writings and
pictures on the subject exist would be a
perfect spy however this was all
ultimately little more than speculation
Walter was barely any further along than
when he started there were multiple
points in his investigations where
Walter seriously considered giving up
until finally he had a major
breakthrough Dr Bartholomew Hughes and
Dr John marich were two scientists that
had performed extensive research into
z55 and who Walter hoped might have the
answers he sought about the self-
keeping secret these scientists were the
first to discover the anti-mimetic
nature of 055 performing numerous tests
on d-class Personnel to see if it was
possible to create feasible written
records sketches or any other records or
Impressions that could bypass its
anomalous effects the disorienting
memory ruining effects of 055 also
extend to any materials concerning
055 it seems to be a truly uncrackable
code but Dr Hughes may have finally
found some cracks in the armor for
starters the fact that we're able to
remember that 055 is an antimic is an
ironic exception ction to its
anti-emetic qualities this Revelation
also inspired another realization from
Dr Hughes would it be possible to
discover more about 055 from the process
of deduction rather than the typical
induction in other words could they
possibly learn about 055 by figuring out
all the things it isn't rather than what
it is Dr Mar designed an experiment with
Dr Hughes to explore this Theory they
designed the experiment around a simple
question is 055 not spherical in
designing the question to specifically
find out what 055 isn't they hope to
subvert the anomaly's anti-mimetic
powers Walter was fascinated by this
potential method of getting answers
marich and Hughes found that while the
questioning process for those exposed
was often arduous and frustrating they
could now definitely say that 055 is not
a sphere it is theoretically possible to
discover the true nature of 055 by an
almost endless barrage of deductive
questions the WEA command would
authorize the resources for such
extensive testing is still an open
question Walter in his desperation
begged marich and Hughes for clearance
to view z55 himself the Curiosity had
become too great during his search to
just walk away with the single fact that
055 wasn't spherical he needed to see
this thing and after several weeks of
filling out forms and cutting red tape
his wish was finally granted Walter
Banbridge was allowed a private audience
with SCP
055 the subject of his monthlong
obsession Outsiders observe that Walter
spent just over an hour in the
containment chamber taking photos
drawing sketches writing down notes
recording audio logs and reciting memory
pneumonics he was pulling out every stop
to counteract the anti-mimetic effects
of the self- keeping secret he was
adamant that he would not be defeated by
his non-spherical Nemesis not after all
this time and effort once his time in
the 055 containment chamber was over he
retired back to his office to finally
digitize his exhaustive findings so that
his supervisor Mr kovat would finally
get off his back Walter smiled took a
deep breath and began to type SCP 059
ker class this anomaly is a radioactive
mineral that emits a unique radiation
known as Delta radiation exposure to
this radiation has caused strange fungal
growths on the
infected wait what was this supposed to
be about again oh well it couldn't have
been that important those blasted
Foundation rats had done it again SCP
682 the hardto destroy reptile sat in
its tank of highly concentrated acid and
seeed at the world it had been placed in
and what a miserable terrible world it
was he hated it and he hated every
single soul that occupied it and
especially the hypocritical monsters in
the lab coats that ran this sham of an
organization whenever the reptile wasn't
speaking normally to bark threats and
profanities at its human jailers it was
quietly listening taking everything in
and how the things it heard made its
blood boil more than the corrosive fluid
forever eating into its carpes what
high-minded ideas these worthless Apes
had about themselves El were cold not
cruel what a sick joke every moment for
the reptile was a different kind of Hell
the Baseline of existence was a certain
dull fizzling pain as he melted as
quickly as his cells could divide his
only reprieve from this was being
dragged into a testing chamber for some
even worse pain perhaps burned or sliced
or chewed at by a mutant rabbit or
crushed by bananas or torn apart by
wires and hooks or beaten and bashed by
some mad swordsman or having his mind
invaded and attacked by a Rogue Soul in
a cursed necklace if this was only cold
then the reptile hated to even imagine
what the SCP Foundation considered cruel
after all there were monsters more
powerful than him out there the hanged
king or the Devourer of Worlds could
handedly destroy their wretched ball of
rock if they so choose to he wasn't the
most sadistic or evil of the beasts
these maniacs and white coats had faced
those who wored with him met a quick
death at his claws and fangs would that
nightmarish old man afford his victim
such a luxury or that Unstoppable
psychopath in the old police car and yet
it was his file that bore the addendum
SCP 682 must be destroyed as soon as
possible and why seemingly only because
he could take it and the foundation
always had new toys it wanted to test on
their favorite punching bag of course he
attempted to escape but wouldn't you is
freedom not an inalienable right the
foundation would cry but look at the
terrible crimes he's committed look at
the lives he's taken as they always do
let he who is without sin draw the first
Acid Bath he knew on some level if he
were to make a tally the foundation's
crimes would far outnumber his own the
only difference was that they deluded
themselves into believing all acts of
Cruelty are permissible in service of
their greater good if they all had but
one head the reptile would Claw from
their shoulders a group of incredibly
well-armed and well- armored guards
entered the room training all their
weapons on him he hadn't summoned the
energy to escape today and that meant
only one thing they were going to take
another swing at killing him again oh
goody another attempt that would leave
him momentarily in absolute agony and
allow neither of them to to gain any
ground he'd grow numb to attempt son his
life by now whatever they had waiting
for him in the other room he'd be ready
for it the guards removed him from his
Acid Bath And while he was still trying
to regenerate his muscles and nerves
enough to move they dragged him into the
testing chamber it was always a mystery
wondering what they'd be poking or
prodding him with today but when he was
first dragged into the chamber it was
empty those were always the worst ones
when he was left some Sitting Duck
waiting for the foundation in their
infinite malice to choose the form of
the wouldbe Destroyer what would be
behind door number one a box a large
wooden box was pushed into the room and
the door closed behind it how curious
the hard to destroy reptile began to
approach the Box sniffing at the air it
made no sound in there but something
about that smell something eily familiar
it was different this time with a soft
pop the Box fell apart its walls falling
in different directions like the pedal
of a blooming flower and the second the
hard to destroy reptile saw what lurked
inside it felt an unfamiliar cold Barb
of Terror hook into the soft warm flesh
of its heart the thing inside the Box
had been called SCP 173 by the SCP
Foundation but that wasn't how the
reptile knew it it was a primordial
nightmare an ancient horror the stone
devil the killer in the dark the quern
which had mercilessly and gleefully
slaughtered so much of the reptiles very
species back when 682 was known as the
atan keno and here it was ready to
finish the job SCP 682 let out an
involuntary Screech of pure horror and
fled backwards keeping its eyes fixed on
the monster at all times he moved back
until he hit the far wall of the
containment chamber until still he could
go no further his mind was flooded and
his heart was racing he never thought
he'd see this monster again he'd hoped
it would never cross his path again
perhaps even held out hope that the
Abomination had been slain destroyed
scattered to the winds and yet here it
was looking at him the reptile called
out you fools you have no idea what
you've done this thing mark my words it
would be your ruin
it will Slaughter every single one of
you but its appeals to reason with its
captors in their own interest for once
fell on utterly uninterested ears 6
hours of this past the reptile spending
every second of it for the first time in
a long time fearing for his life a group
of observing Foundation scientists
merely noted A peculiar reaction of
distress from 682 and ordered a
decorated mobile task for Sharpshooter
with a Barret 50 caliber sniper rifle
with armor-piercing rounds to initiate
phase two of the Cross test in a sudden
flash of sound and pain the Sharpshooter
blew away both of scp-682's staring eyes
the simultaneous instruction went out
for all observing members of personnel
to avert their gaze just for a moment
682 could certainly regenerate its eyes
quickly but nothing was quite as fast as
an unobserved SCP 173 the reptile
screeched in pain as it heard the
monster snapping its body parts leaving
it thoroughly mutilated when the group
of observing scientists looked back they
saw it which is to say SCP 173 standing
before a heavily damaged SCP 682 as
though incredibly proud of its handiwork
internally 682 thanked a Creator it
despised for the fact that the observers
looked back and spared it from the
onslaught that soulless Stone monster
had Unleashed on it a scientist working
for the foundation would later remark
after review it appears SCP 173 was
unable to do lethal damage to SCP 682
due to a major difference in physical
size a possible repeat of this test may
be made if SCP 682 is damaged enough to
reduce its physical Mass to a level
equal with SCP 173 but 682 knew deep
down this wasn't the truth it had
nothing to do with physical size if the
kurn had truly willed it he never would
have left that room the monster only
wanted to extend the torment and this
time SCP 682 wouldn't let him he
regenerated adapted and came back ready
682 developed a number of eyes far more
than before that remained fixed on SCP
173 paralyzing it it crawled back up
onto the wall and simply stared once
again the observing scientists ordered
the Sharpshooter to take aim in open
fire but this time the bullets had no
effect SCP 682 had developed a thick
clear carapace over the surface of its
new eyes ensuring that nothing would
break its eye contact with that
murderous little monster this time it
would not lose but for all the time that
682 stared 173 said nothing as always it
just stood there the strange pattern of
its face that nasty bloody RAR Shack
splotch looked almost like a mocking
smile it conceded nothing it seemed to
say go on get an eye full I have all the
time in the universe and everyone looks
away eventually even you atan K penu let
the Eternal Silence of your brethren be
a lesson to you all you will hear is
crunch 682 kept up the staring contest
for 12 hours before it was taken back to
its Acid Bath thoroughly shaken by its
experience it had always despised its
terrible captors but now a new shade of
Darkness had entered its narrow
emotional lexicon fear true fear fear an
acknowledgement deep down in its muscle
tissue and guts that there was something
out there that could truly hurt it the
terrible kurn was alive and thirsty for
blood the researchers who conducted this
test considered it an interesting
partial success while 682 was quaking in
its tank thinking about 173 they were
brainstorming the best move to take next
regarding potential pairings between 682
and 173 a Plucky researcher noted that
096 had also gotten SCP 682 on the ropes
so maybe they should send in 173 with a
photo of scp096 taped to its chest a
member of the 05 Council intervened
before this got too far saying no
absolutely not setting aside the problem
of SCP 682 and SCP 173 that cannot be
observed for fear of triggering a
response from scp096 is a
self-perpetuating catastrophe that the
foundation does not under any reasonable
circumstances have the slightest desire
to unleash denied with vment the
researcher who suggested this idea felt
supremely embarrassed and retired
briefly to one of the employee bathrooms
to have a good cry before returning to
the brainstorming session researcher
matus a more experienced member of
personnel had a stroke of Genius he
reminded the assembled researchers that
they had recently performed another
semi-successful experiment on 682 using
their deadly High Precision Blades they
were able to slice and dice 682 into a
series of orph blobs sure these blobs
may have attacked and killed some DCL
classes before reforming into the OG
nasty reptile but each of these blobs
were the perfect size to be murdered by
SCP 173 it eliminated the size
differential and put these two on an
even playing field and on that even
playing field it stood to reason that SC
SCP 173 might win the cross test was
greenlit and a researcher named Dr
Shenron was put in charge of overseeing
the operation
and this time due to Foundation
incompetence and a greater degree of
mental preparedness by SCP 682 they were
in for a complete disaster 682 and 173
were brought into the same containment
chamber 682 could feel the latent fear
welling up inside itself so it did the
thing that it knew the best it tried to
stoke up its rage its hatred the fury
and spite that had kept it going through
so many torturous attempts on its life
it would not die at the hands of this
Stone monster and if it was its Destiny
then it would ensure with its dying
wretched breaths it would destroy this
terrible Beast once and for all it would
shatter it and ensure it never put
itself back together suddenly the high
Precision Blades were deployed it was an
endless volley of cutting that dashed
the two deadly anomalies to pieces like
a giant As Seen On TV Slap Chop because
the machine had been calibrated for its
body 682 was sliced into 12,000 perfect
cubes and 173 had been cut into a pile
of lumpy irregular chunks a vacuum
system was then activated to separate
both anomalies into different chambers
so 173 could reform and begin the
assault but miraculously for 682 the
vacuum system failed 2D classes were
sent in to recalibrate the system but
things quickly got even worse many of
the 682 cubes formed the same gelatinous
masses that they did in the previous
High Precision Blades test and began
attacking and killing one of the DCL
classes the other naturally turned to
look at this horrifying display which
meant nobody was paying attention to SCP
173 immediately the sculpture reformed
and snapped the surviving dcl's neck
before turning its attention to SCP 682
the emergency incineration system failed
so all the foundation could hope for was
mutually assured destruction until they
got the situation back under control
however the foundation had under under
estimated 682s intelligence and tactical
reasoning while the gelatinous mutated
Globs of its flesh attacked 173 smashing
and cracking its concrete body as it
killed and splattered them the remainder
of 682s Flesh formed a smaller version
of itself which began staring at 173
this froze the sculpture in place while
the mutated flesh monster smashed into
it slowly breaking it down for the first
time in as long as it could remember 682
felt genuine Glee the thrill of Revenge
the glory of an ancient foe vanquished
it would now slay the terrible quern as
its ancestors had tried to do so many
times before and failed but this reptile
would not fail until of course the SCP
Foundation monsters that they were
decided to put their finger on the scale
the same Foundation mobile task force
Sharpshooter who'd been there during the
first 173 cross test was still there
still ready to carry out his duties on
the order of the researchers he fired
another two shots blowing out the eyes
of this new smaller 682 while it
regenerated its precious eyes 173 went
on a rampage mercilessly slaughtering
every single one of the eyeless Blobs of
mutated flesh it smashed each one Beyond
repair until only it and the smaller 682
remained luckily for 682 its eyes
regenerated complete with the familiar
bulletproof covering just in time to
hold back 173 from killing it the two
remained locked in a staring contest of
pure hatred for a solid 17 hours before
the test was eventually called off but
the horrors continued exhausted by the
ordeal already SCP 682 was sedated and
returned to its containment chamber
without incident where it regenerated
back to its default state things weren't
so easy with SCP 173 while a team
transported it back to its containment
chamber there was a power outage in the
hall and things went dark and
considering SCP 173 in addition to the
sculpture and the peanut could also be
nicknamed instant Killing Spree just at
Darkness it won't surprise you to hear
there were no survivors 173 killed
everyone in the hall then escaped out
into the wider facility causing a
sitewide Containment Breach and a huge
number of casualties the cause of the
electrical short that kickstarted this
massacre was Trace back to Dr shenron's
tampering with the incinerator system
this got the doctor formally reprimanded
stripped of his titles and his memories
and relieved of his duty but the worst
was still very much to come for everyone
involved including SCP 682 because the
true terrifying potential of SCP 173 was
soon going to be Unleashed and when that
happened nowhere would be safe on what
was otherwise a very normal day in a
very normal procedure when a few DCL
classes were sent into SC SCP 173 cell
something extraordinary and terrible
happened SCP 173 multiplied like a
single cell organism undergoing mitosis
173 somehow just split into two equal
copies of itself two DCL classes were
killed in this first duplication event
but they were just the beginning soon
enough people would look back so fondly
on the days when there were only a mere
two of these things the foundation and
682 for all their disagreements are very
much alike both are always vying for
control over their situations and both
achieve this through understanding and
adapting to whatever is threatening them
as SCP 173 continued to multiply the
foundation did what they could to adapt
and regain control they tried to contain
specific instances in smaller
containment units they tried to create
new methods for permanent observation
they even tried shipping them off to the
moon but none of it did any good SCP 173
continued to duplicate they escaped
began spreading further they killed half
a million civilians in 48 hours and
believe believe us when we tell you they
were just getting started the ever
growing Army of 173 instances went on
massive Killing Spree every night taking
out huge swaths of the civilian
population as they scrambled and
panicked in the dark and they weren't
just going after civilians evidently
much like 682 173 had a grudge against
the SCP Foundation for all those Decades
of imprisonment the 173 Army began
locating surrounding and destroying
entire Foundation containment sites and
killing off all the staff and the
anomalies inside of all the entities in
containment that might one day go XK and
destroy the world as we know it not many
people had 173 on their bingo card if
only they'd listened to 682s warnings
and reallocated their termination
resources to 173 things may have turned
out differently and speaking of our
scaly old foe 682 sat in an empty
chamber it' been days since anyone had
come in to check on it all fled or dead
from snapped neck one of the two he
thought about escaping containment but
given the blood baths going on outside
all the time what would even be the
point all that was really left was time
and that was a rapidly depleting
resource he just needed to wait for that
thing to come and see him again SCP 682
blinked and there it was standing before
him looking blink and there was more
blink so many of them so so many blink
surrounded on on all sides by that
terrible creature too many to fight too
many to win just waiting watching
mocking him there was only one thing
left to do blink it was a beautiful
September day but Shawn Taylor was
trapped in his car in one of the worst
cases of gridlock he had ever seen he
tried to look on the bright side though
and while he was stuck in an unmoving
car at least he had a pleasant view of
the wide shimmering Lake just off the
road next to him he was admiring the
scene when tiny drops of rain started
landing on his windshield that's funny
there wasn't a cloud in the sky a moment
ago there was something off about the
rain though it looked dirty a rusty red
color was that blood he didn't have time
to think about it because just then a
thick dense Mist began to roll over the
lake a fog of blood just off the side of
the road he could see a huge silhouette
rising out of the water is that an old
sub Marine what Shawn didn't know was
that he was about to have an encounter
with SCP
1861 also known as the HMS winter shimer
a ghostly submarine with strange and
terrifying effects Shawn and the other
drivers stuck in traffic that day were
far from the first people to have a
dangerous brush with this legendary
vessel according to SCP Foundation
records the HMS winter shimer has been
appearing since as early as
1916 the first recorded incident
occurred in the British Seaside town of
insouth on sea you won't find this town
on any Maps or in the history books and
you're about to find out why the 500
population of the town which had already
reduced by the wartime draft into the
currently raging great world war awoke
to Red Skies on February 6th
1916 citizens left their homes to
investigate only to find their entire
town had been enveloped in a thick Red
Mist the swelling Crimson clouds up
ahead began to rain showering the town
in a hail of viscous red goop anyone
unlucky enough to tasted would say that
this strange rain was a dreadful mix of
salt and copper this was because as the
foundation would later determine the
rain and fog was a disgusting
combination of saltwater human blood and
human cerebros spinal fluid but the real
threat was Rising just beyond the beach
technically speaking the HMS winter
shimer vessel is designated as SCP 1861
daa it appears to be a World War I era
British B Class submarine designed by
Vickers for the Royal Navy in 1904 by
1916 this particular type of boat was
already on its way to being Obsolete and
were largely deployed in Malta far from
the active fronts so one of these
vessels appearing on an otherwise
unremarkable stretch of English
Coastline should have been a clue that
something was terribly wrong
but the poor residents of insouth on sea
didn't know the half of it soon figures
in what appeared to be archaic diving
gear began emerging from the winter
shimer and made their way into the
township they seemed terrified running
up to and frantically screaming at any
local they could find please listen to
me something terrible is about to happen
here we need you to come with us or
you're all going to die you must believe
us the locals were frightened by what
they heard they'd been listening to news
reports of the Great War unfolding
across the globe for 2 years now had it
finally come to them they pictured
shells raining down from the sky
decimating their defenseless little town
in a rain of fire the Navy must have
been brought in to save them before the
German bombardment began while some took
more convincing than others the men in
diving suits known as SCP
on to the submarine hundreds of them
many couldn't believe their eyes as they
watch scores of people disappear in
front of them into the dark bowels of
the winter shimer where were they all
going how would they all fit in there
but it was too late for any of them to
back out now the vessel submerged once
more and everyone was gone the entire
population of insouth on sea had
disappeared in a rain of fog and blood
never to be seen again the foundation
wiped all records of the town from
existing and delivered appropriate
amnestic treatment to anyone who still
mentioned or remembered insouth on sea
the fate of those who bored the HMS
winter shimer is always the same vanish
from the face of the Earth explained
Away by the foundation as accidental
death by extreme weather event there
have been hundreds of documented
sightings of SCP 1861 and the anomalous
weather event can occur near any body of
water wide enough to accommodate SCP
1861 D's comms Tower and topmost
platform depth does not seem to be any
hindrance of the submarine appearing and
it can even manifest in water that's
just a few inches deep as Shawn and the
other unfortunate victims of the rush
hour traffic were being showered in
thick red droplets from above a crimson
Mist rolled in between the cars sea had
heard of so-called freak weather events
before like raining frogs and fish but
this was something different and it
frightened him he could see now that the
silhouette rising from the Lake really
was an old submarine and he watched as a
legion of mysterious figures disembarked
from the vessel and began spilling onto
the road the men in ancient looking
diving suits walked among the cars and
one of them approached Shawn's car he
began tapping frantically on the window
and Shawn could tell he was yelling
something Shawn was scared and more but
more than anything else he was confused
against his better judgment he rolled
down the window just a crack to hear
what the man was saying his British
accented voice muted by the diving suit
the man frantically told him sir please
listen to me I'm Lieutenant Samuel
Ramsey of the HMS winter shimer we're
evacuating the area please you've got to
come with me we're in danger out here
HMS Shawn thought isn't that what they
call British ships what was a British
submarine doing in the middle of a lake
in the United States through his
windshield Shawn could already see other
men in diving suits leading people from
the cars out towards the submarine
something had to be going on here
something big lieutenant Ramsey was
still banging away at the glass of Sha's
window becoming increasingly agitated
sir if you won't comply with my orders
I'm within my rights to take you by
force for your own safety Shawn could
feel the fear setting in but he didn't
know what else to do he turned off the
car and took off his seat belt he was
just about to open the door when there
was a tap on the passenger side window
of his car it was a soldier in what
looked to be Advanced tactical gear
there were several soldiers directing
cars to drive on the shoulder to get
around the mess of stop automobiles
Shawn looked to his left and the Man in
the diving suit was gone the soldier
tapped again and Shawn didn't need to be
told twice he followed his directions
and drove around the traffic jam and out
of the Mist a half mile down the road
Shawn was stopped by another group of
soldiers and given an amnestic he drove
away never knowing how close he had come
to Vanishing in the bowels of SCP 1861 d
a Shawn was lucky that one of the SCP
foundation's mobile task forces had
taken over the situation but they were
too late to help those who had already
complied with SCP 1861 B's orders and
boarded the winter shimer the task force
made it their business to save whoever
they could but that wasn't their only
directive the foundation had recorded a
huge number of SCP 1861 instances since
1916 and now they were finally going to
figure out what was going on inside the
foundation had already discovered that
those taken onto the winter shimer don't
simply disappear once on board the
submarine they are forced into a diving
suit of their own which transforms them
into new instances of SCP
1861-62 the foundation dispatched two
members of d-class personnel who were
familiar with one another into the Red
Mist one was instructed not to interact
with SCP 1861 B while the other named s
was ordered to enter the submarine his
mission was to report back all findings
to Foundation researcher Dr clutch
during the next 1861 event the d-class
who remained on Shore was brought in
Once More by the mobile task force
during the September event that Shawn
witnessed they checked each diving suit
wearing anomaly until they heard a
familiar voice muffled by The Mask it
was s and he'd been transformed into an
instance of SCP
the human declass receiving questions
from Dr clutch via remote broadcast
commenced the interview of his former
friend it is from this vital interview
that much of the foundation's knowledge
of the mysterious HMS winter shimer is
drawn according to S the interior of the
winter shimer which is a long narrow
passageway is a spatial anomaly that
seems to stretch on forever this
explains how vast number of people like
the entire population of insouth on sea
can disappear into the submarine at once
s reported that about an hour after
entering the vessel the hatch closed and
the interior began rapidly filling with
water as the submarine descended
prisoners of the winter shimer were
faced with two choices sued up or drown
few chose the latter option and as soon
as the suit was on the transformation
had begun as soon as everyone was suited
up and the submarine had fully descended
causing the 1861 weather event to
dissipate on Earth the winter shimer had
effectively entered an alternate
Dimension the airlock opened and the new
recruits were instructed to step outside
and take a look around the winter shimer
veterans informed the new Sailors that
everyone on land was likely already dead
by this point when s first exited the
submarine he commented on everything
around him looking eerily similar to how
it looked on land before the Mist
descended but with one key difference it
seemed as though everything was
underwater well not quite that it was
almost as though everything was water
like the world had taken on a kind of
flowing liquid state s and the others
existed in this otherw worldly land of
Living Water for 6 months and as the
months passed things only got stranger
they found that they neither needed to
eat nor sleep according to S all they
did was breathe and passed the time by
exploring and talking to one another
anyone who attempted to take off their
suit would dissolve and diffuse into the
same liquid that surrounded them Dr
clutch asked s about the other
inhabitants of this alien realm and this
was when things got truly disturbing
there were dead humans and animals
floating all over the place missing
their eyes as though they'd been scooped
out and missing their mouths as though
they'd been bitten out of their face by
some kind of huge Predator their empty
eye sockets bled constantly and South
theorized that this may have something
to do with the anomalous blood Mists of
SCP
1861 when asked to provide more
information on on why all the corpses
were mutilated in this way s said that
one of his superiors on the winter
shimer told him the Watcher of eyes and
biter of teeth deemed them worthy
whatever this mysterious being was it
seemed to be a powerful figure within
1861 Water World and S Felt lucky that
he never had a direct runin with the
creature himself for his final request
Dr clutch asked s to attempt to remove
his suit the foundation had learned in
previous instances of 186 61 that the
diving suits have anomalous durability
and it was impossible for anyone other
than the wearer to remove them hence why
the foundation could never deal with
the second s removed his helmet gallons
of seawater poured out and the now empty
suit collapsed to the ground s's body
was never found only some teeth and a
pair of eyes were recovered the eyes
were later confirmed to be belonging to
a young girl and the teeth were
identified as having come from a
European Red Deer and so the dark
mystery of the HMS winter shimer
continues because of the unpredictable
nature of its appearances and the
resulting difficulty of containing it
the winter shimer has earned a ker
classification the only containment
procedure currently employed by the SCP
Foundation is for mobile task forces to
try and intercept the submarine when
appearances are reported and hopefully
prevent or at least reduce the
kidnapping of civilians with so many
questions left unanswered all we can say
for certain is that if a Red Mist ever
descends on you and a stranger in a
diving suit tells you you're in grave
danger he's absolutely right stop me if
you've heard heard this one before a
young man was driving home from work
late one rainy night when he spotted a
woman in a white dress and a red sweater
walking along the shoulder of the road
concerned for her safety he slowed down
and rolled down the window so he could
talk to her when he asked where she was
going she said she was walking to her
parents' house the man pulled over and
offered her a ride that she accepted the
woman gave him the address of her home
hopped in the back seat and the man
drove off he sensed that she must have
been cold from walking in the rain so he
cranked up the car's heater to help her
dry off soon she removed her heavy red
sweater and placed it on the seat next
to her the man tried to make friendly
conversation asking if the woman had a
job what she was studying at school
where'd she been that day but she
remained quiet staring out the window
until they drove past an old graveyard
the woman began pounding on the glass of
the car as if she desperately wanted
something unsure of what to do the man
pulled over but before he could asked
her what was happening she had gotten
out of the car he exited the car to try
and find her but the woman was nowhere
to be seen she must have somehow ran off
confused the man got back in his car and
drove away he went on his way and didn't
think of it again until the next day
when he noticed her sweater was still in
the back of his car he decided to go to
the house she had originally given him
the address for and give it back to her
he found the home without any trouble
but when he knocked on the door the old
woman who answered it was confused by
his story she told him that her daughter
couldn't have possibly left her sweater
in his car because she died in a car
accident 30 years ago the vanishing
hitchhiker is a classic ghost story with
the details varying from place to place
and Storyteller to Storyteller in
Chicago she goes by Resurrection Mary
named after the graveyard she asks for
rides to in okanawa Japan she's known as
the night walker of Nago and she only
appears to taxi drivers
in Kent England she's Suzanne a bride
killed in a car wreck on the way to her
bachelorette party in North Carolina her
name is Lydia and in Hawaii she's
believed to be the goddess Pelle in
human form but as far as our friends at
the SCP Foundation are concerned the
vanishing hitchhiker's name is Mary
talish also known as SCP
1337 on the 19th of May 1952 College
sophomore Mary talish was abducted on
her way to class in her hometown of Muny
Indiana when police found her body 2
weeks later her eyes and heart had been
torn from her body in a ritualistic
fashion and she had scrapes and bruises
that suggested she had been beaten
before her murder her killers were never
caught and her body was returned to her
family for burial intance in Cemetery
starting on the 19th of June that same
year someone matching Mary's description
a Caucasian woman with blonde hair
standing 150 cm tall and wearing a red
sweater was spotted trying to fly down
passing Vehicles along Mayflower Road
since then every month on the 19th Mary
has been cited along that stretch of
road and every month the same scenario
plays out Mary gives anyone who picks
her up directions to her parents' house
then on the way she instructs the driver
to stop at the graveyard where she was
buried she vanishes from the car leaving
her sweater the driver of the car tries
to return the sweater to her parents
house only to be told that Mary talish
was dead when the SCP Foundation was
made aware of Mary tales's pattern of
Haunting in the late 50s they set up a
system where agents would Patrol
Mayflower Road at hourly intervals with
the intention of picking Mary up agents
were sent on their own in non-foundation
cars and instructed to stick to the
accepted script of the vanishing
hitchhiker Legend without attempting to
engage Mary in further conversation
Mary's parents were also given E-class
agent status to keep them from speaking
about the haunting and told that the
foundation was working on a way to set
the spirit to rest early attempts to
study The Apparition were inconclusive
it proved impossible for the foundation
to relocate her or trigger her
manifestation outside of the 19th of
every month and attempts to analyze her
sweater were fruitless since if the
sweater wasn't returned to the talish
family home it would simply vanish from
containment at or around sunset on the
next 19th for 20 years SCP 1337 events
continued to happen as normal d-class
Personnel under the instruction of the
foundation would pick Mary up drive her
past the cemetery and return her sweater
to her parents it was business as usual
and in fact it was one of the more
sedate reoccurring apparitions the
foundation had to deal with but as you
might have guessed that piece wouldn't
last forever enter Dr Lawson who in
1972 was placed in charge of all
resources regarding SCP 1337 Dr Lawson
was getting sick of all this Phantom
hitchhiker business and while most of
the foundation was happy to keep this
routine going Lawson thought that the
continual picking up and dropping off of
Mary talish and her red sweater was a
waste of the foundation's valuable time
after all it was the early ' 7s the
price of oil was at an all-time high so
the expense of sending car after car up
and down the same road for a solid day
once a month just to pick up a ghost was
more trouble than it was worth so Lawson
started developing a plan one that he
didn't go through the proper Foundation
channels to approve he reasoned that the
reason Mary's ghost kept coming back was
because she wanted something since
always asked for a ride home then it
must mean she wanted to return back to
her parents so logic followed that if
she had nothing or no one to go back to
then she'd stop appearing on the 18th of
June 1973 Lawson went ahead with his
plan without his superior's knowledge
and ordered the execution of Mary
tales's parents as well as the immediate
demolition of their family home
according to his journals Lawson had
hoped that his attempt at
decommissioning 1337 would significantly
cut the foundation's gas bills freeing
up valuable funds at which point he'd
surely be promoted in recognition of his
Brilliance but that wasn't what happened
Lawson was demoted from team leader to
junior staff and only kept on 1337
detail out of the belief that without a
family to return to Lawson would become
the new focal point of The Haunting
should Mary talish ever return though
Lawson's actions weren't at all above
board even by a SCP Foundation standards
they did seem to have worked the 19th of
June came and went without a single Mary
sighting and she wasn't seen the next
month either a full year went by without
any sign of the Mayflower Road
Apparition satisfied with this turn of
events the foundation made the decision
to officially reclassify SCP 1337 from
safe to Safe decommissioned and the gas
money that was budgeted for the
Mayflower Road Patrol was redirected to
the SCP 682 tank acid fund but even
though everything seemed to have been
sorted out Lawson wasn't entirely
satisfied and not just because of his
demotion whether it was Intuition or
merely guilt induced paranoia is unclear
but he suspected that Mary was still out
there somewhere at first he thought that
she might show up on the anniversary of
her parents' deaths but then that date
came and went as did eight more
anniversaries after it finally on the
19th of June 1983 Lawson decided he had
to see for himself fitted with recording
equipment he drove alone in a
non-foundation standard car down that
lonely stretch of road where so many
before him had stopped to pick up that
mysterious blonde woman with the red
sweater he had to prove to himself that
she wouldn't show up that he had really
and truly gotten rid of her for good it
was it was about 5:00 in the evening
when he reached Mayflower Road at first
he didn't experience anything strange he
scanned the roadside looking for the
Phantom hitchhiker walking along it but
there was nobody there Dr Lawson
breathed a sigh of relief he may have
orchestrated the deaths of two innocent
people but at least it hadn't been for
nothing he turned on the recorder he
brought with him and log that nothing
had happened SCP 1337 had been
permanently neutralized as he approached
the te intersection and prepared to turn
onto Marsh Avenue he looked up to adjust
his rearview mirror to his horror he
found that he wasn't alone in the car
someone was in the seat behind him
someone with blonde hair and a red
sweater his last transmission consisted
only of wait who the hell are you before
the recording abruptly stopped Lawson's
car was found soon after by Foundation
agents Lawson was dead in the front seat
bruised and bloody with his eyes and
heart ripped out in a ritualistic
fashion just the way Mary talish had
been found all the way back in
1952 it turns out that Mary hadn't been
neutralized after all she'd just been
waiting for a chance to get revenge on
the man who killed her family and Mary
didn't stop with Dr Lawson no longer
does she appear walking along the road
waiting for someone to offer her a ride
before disappearing without incident now
should someone pass by without offering
a ride she will appear in their backseat
before reenacting the method of her own
death upon the driver and her physical
appearance has changed too whereas
before she looked like the image of a
pretty young woman before her tragedy
now recording show that she appears with
the wounds of her death present her eyes
gouged out in their sockets and a
massive hole in her chest where her
heart should be the same wounds she
inflicts on her victims the SCP
Foundation has tried closing off and
eventually destroying the road but that
has only resulted in Mary manifesting at
other locations in and around Muny
Foundation documents reveal that any
Back Road in the city can potentially
serve as host to a 1337 event and all
attempts to contain The Apparition have
failed the only way someone who has seen
Mary can avoid her wrath is by stopping
to pick her up at which point she will
dematerialize before reappearing on
another road mobile task forces have
been unsuccessful as Mary only appears
to those driving alone and all agents
who have been sent on solo missions to
apprehend and her have resulted in the
death of the agent as SCP 1337 was
reinstated this time as uclid class
currently the foundation's method of
managing SCP 1337 is to dispatch a
security team on the 19th of every month
to monitor all the places where a
potential sighting could take place as
soon as signs of a manifestation are
identified a remotely controlled vehicle
containing a single D class is driven to
the location once Mary appears in the
car the the car is piloted to the empty
lot where her home used to stand and the
remains of the d-class are then disposed
of like a lot of the stories that could
pass down as urban legends the story of
SCP 1337 has a lesson that can be taken
away from it this SCP started off as an
ordinary local haunting no more deadly
than Lydia Suzanne Resurrection Mary or
any of the countless other local
versions of the vanishing hitchhiker
story but thanks to one Rogue Foundation
doctor and and his desire to rush what
he thought would be an efficient
solution the spirit not only became
harder to control but also much more
violent and bloodthirsty than anyone was
prepared to deal with so if there's
anything we can learn here it's that no
matter if you're a student an office
worker or a researcher with the SCP
Foundation think twice about cutting
Corners it might save you a little bit
of time and money in the short term but
in the long term the results could be
fatal it was November 20th 2019 and the
helicopter circled far above in the
freezing wind of the Antarctic SCP
Foundation site director Jason Monroe
looked down at the isolated above ground
facilities of provisional site
[Music]
344-1314 29 mobile task force units and
73 members of d-class personnel had gone
missing here and never been found Monroe
thought he was here for a routine
investigation into negligence and
mismanagement but little did he know he
was in for so much more this is the
story of SCP
5545 and one man's journey into his own
worst nightmare literally but this
nightmare began a long time ago 300
years to be exact and like most
nightmares it started as a dream that
dream was one of expansion
National Powers across Europe wanted to
be the first to conquer the globe and
expand into new territories and sent
countless exploratory missions off into
the unknown to achieve this goal any
history book will tell you that the
first Outsiders to lay eyes upon the
continent of Antarctica did so in 1820
the reality is that the first ones to
get there actually landed in the late
1700s the hapless explorers ventured
into Mainland Antarctica and made base
camps before searching and digging for
any useful resources nearby They Came
Upon a strange Discovery a hallway
hidden beneath the ice not a passage in
the ice but a true hallway complete with
light fixtures the confused explorers
ventured down into these impossible
hallways and for many of them it would
be the last thing they ever did no
matter how long they walked it seemed
like the hallways just kept going as
they continued to walk for hours they
hoped to find something and anything and
eventually they did they passed from
these hallways into somewhere different
altogether and most of them were never
heard from again those who did manage to
escape often died or took their own
lives soon after whatever it was they
discovered down there they didn't want
to live with it on their minds it's
believed that over 70 Colonial explorers
disappeared or died this way and that
most who found these endless hallways
beneath the Antarctic Ice never returned
the multiple anomalous objects and
phenomena that make up SCP 5545 came
into the foundation's hands several
centuries later on September 18 2003
when during an expedition into the
Antarctic they to found the endless
hallways the foundation built
provisional site 3441 around them hoping
to safely seal them off from any other
unwitting Antarctic explorers or
researchers but there was something else
lurking beneath the ice in Antarctica
something dangerous the hallways were
design ated as SCP
55451 and were thought to be the extent
of the anomalous activity at the site
but soon SCP 55 45-2 was discovered
which resulted in the deaths of 16
researchers so what exactly is 55 45-2
it's an entity so volatile that even
knowing about it is considered to be a
Containment Breach and as a result it's
kept in provisional site
344-2 unlike site 344 1 344-2 isn't a
physical space it's conceptual
accessible only through the endless
hallways created with the express
purpose of keeping
55451 and
55452 separate why because whenever the
two come into contact the result is
55453 the network of endless hallways
expanding if they remained in contact
the hallways would continue to expand
and the entire planet could be filled
with endless hallways ways in Just 4 to
6 hours while the two are apart though
55 45-3 reverses but it always would
take just a few hours to throw the whole
world into a chaos of infinite hallways
SCP 5545 has been given the
classification safe wait we're dealing
with a mysterious and volatile anomaly
that claimed a huge number of lives and
still somehow eludes True Foundation
understanding yet the official SCP
Foundation classification is safe how
could this be Monroe was the director of
site 58 and was the definition of No
Nonsense prior to taking the site
director position he was a decorated
member of mobile task force a of 10 and
helped contain numerous ker class
anomalies he'd been around the
proverbial block when it came to
anomalous activity and something about
SCP 5545 and the management of
provisional site 344 seemed awfully
suspicious to him and he had questions
like how such an unpredictable anomaly
could be declared safe and why had there
been such a lapse of communication
between the foundation and Dr Gabriel
Reed who'd been running the facility for
the past two decades and most of all
just what exactly was the mysterious SCP
55452 Monroe started to believe that
something terrible had happened at the
site and Reed was covering it all up but
to find out for sure you'd need to go to
Antarctica and investigate it himself
information about this supposedly safe
anomaly was highly classifi those
without 05 clearance could face
termination for snooping but that didn't
scare Jason Monroe he dealt with kter
before he could deal with this or so he
thought Monroe submitted a request and
was granted unanimous approval by the 05
Council to travel to provisional site
344 and get to the bottom of this
mystery he took a chopper to the base
soon after armed with a concealed
firearm and a hostile meme detector or
hmd to test whether the base and its
staff had somehow Fallen Fallen under a
hazardous mimetic effect from SCP
5545 he'd find the answers or die trying
the moment Monroe arrived he couldn't
help but notice the strange way the
staff behaved they seemed listless
almost oppressive when he showed his
credentials to a researcher they simply
said SCP
55452 is contained in site
344-2 his request to see Dr Reed that
night was denied Dr Reed was busy he was
told wait until tomorrow the next day Dr
Monroe met with Dr Reed but the results
of the meeting were underwhelming to say
the least just like the rest of the
staff on the sight he seemed exhausted
as though he hadn't slept in days his
responses were quiet and evasive and he
refused to tell Monroe anything that
wasn't in the official files already
Monroe ran the conversation through the
hmd and found nothing out of the
ordinary what was going on here Monroe
was irritated but not deterred nothing
would stop him from finding out the
truth
the next day he flexed his 05
credentials and hacked into the B's
security system this gave him access to
cameras around site
3441 but more importantly there was a
single camera inside the mysterious site
344-2 jackpot but when he looked at it
the feed was an entirely black screen
with the words SCP
55452 is contained inside
344-2 the footage of the staff in 34 4-1
was equally strange the 18 employees on
site all sat at computer banks with
nothing but static playing on their
screens Monroe kept digging though and
was able to hack into the security
footage of Dr Reed's office as he
watched he discovered a 15minute period
where Reed left the office each day he
could use this brief window to break in
and collect more Intel on SCP
55452 Monroe was so wrapped up in the
investigation that he almost forgot the
more immediate danger around him and
nearly wandered into one of the Endless
hallways of
55451 by mistake he made a note to be
more careful in the future his first
attempt at breaking into Dr Reed's
office didn't produce many answers one
piece of evidence was a blurry picture
of what looked like a mobile task force
entering a 55 45-1 hallway in the dark
another was a spreadsheet featuring all
the Personnel living or dead who worked
at the site but one name and the details
of whether this person was alive or dead
was completely redacted anything
particularly juicy was hidden behind 05
clearance if Monroe wanted the answers
he needed to break through that night he
had a horrific reoccurring nightmare one
that had plagued him since he joined MTF
edat 10 he dreamed that he was in a
fancy dining room with a grand fireplace
the room was full of statues of men and
women the men looked angry and the woman
looked afraid as he approached the
fireplace the ceiling extended
infinitely up into the darkness suddenly
the zombie like body of a teenage girl
appears in the fireplace hanging from a
long thread her eyes look Furious and
full of rage and Monroe somehow knows
that he's the reason for her hate when
he steps into the fireplace in this
dream she attacks him the two intertwine
and they burn forever the one difference
was that in this new iteration of the
dream he blinked upon entering the
fireplace and suddenly he was in the
hallway he woke sure that something was
terribly wrong here but he couldn't give
up now the next day Dr Monroe broke into
Reed's office and made a horrifying
Discovery he found files indicating that
Dr Reed was knowingly sending mobile
task forces and d-class Personnel into
the infinite hallways of 55 45-1 to
their Doom he also found evidence that
Reed and the researchers had been spying
on him somehow intercepting copies of
the notes he had been taking that's when
Dr Reed entered the office and
interrupted him on Ro panicked and Drew
his weapon holding the doctor at
gunpoint he was breaking so many
Foundation rules but right now he feared
for his life the doctor seemed
unbothered by Monroe's threats though he
told Monroe that everything was going to
plan and that he should go back to his
room Monroe was becoming increasingly
paranoid he felt that at any moment
guards might first in and execute him
nothing about this place made sense he
worried he was going insane perhaps the
only way to find answers was to go even
deeper to risk it all and Venture
through the endless hallways to find SCP
55452 himself and finally discover what
this thing actually was Monroe left his
room and stepped into one of the Endless
hallways of 55 45-1 that was located
just across from his dorm he found that
it was a hallway like all the others on
site plane concrete worn of age with
simple light fixtures on the walls he
walked for hours recording with the
concealed device the light suddenly went
out leaving him in complete darkness
when they flicked back on he was in a
very different environment a grand old
carpeted hallway the kind you'd see in
an old mansion he broke into a cold
sweat what was so familiar about this
place he kept walking racked with Terror
until this new hallway finally led him
to the place he'd been seeking site
344-2 the domain of
55452 it was a large poorly lit room
filled with grimacing statues and a
large fireplace at the far end it was
the exact same room from Monroe's dream
with one horrifying difference Monroe
noticed a single white thread hanging
down from the infinite ceiling and when
he looked up to find its source he
screamed there were hundreds of bodies
hanging and swinging from the ceiling
above him everyone who SCP
55452 had ever killed including MTF
members de class personnel and even the
colonial explorers from hundreds of
years before and all of them were him
every single one they had his face and
there hanging in the middle of the room
at ground level was the body of a
teenage girl the one from his dream in
that moment he finally recognized her
she was the girl he killed the first
himy hundreds of years ago much like
Monroe you're probably wondering what is
going on here thanks to Declassified
communication between Dr Reed and the 05
Council we can tell you Jason Monroe was
a man who's been reincarnated hundreds
of times over the last 300 years ever
since he murdered a teenage girl a girl
named Emily his daughter this murder
sparked the existence of SCP 5545 as an
eternally reoccurring punishment for his
crimes since figuring this out the
foundation has kept tabs on Monroe's
reincarnations whether their MTF members
d-class Personnel or even site directors
they see to it that these reincarnations
always find their way back to 55 45-2 to
take his punishment and prevent the
infinite hallway expansion that
threatens to destroy the world it's a
plan everyone is in on everyone except
him but every time he enters that
nightmare haunting room it all comes
rushing back in that moment though he
knew his crime and he somehow knew how
many times this punishment had unfolded
for him he now had two choices repent
and accept the punishment again or leave
and activate 55
45-3 potentially allowing the endless
tunnels to expand across the world like
his many predecessors Monroe made the
decent Choice he accepted his punishment
and allowed his own string to coil
around him as the lights in the room
went off one by one leaving only
Darkness Jason Monroe that version of
him at least was never seen again but
the SCP Foundation is already eyeing up
his next reincarnation and preparing to
let this Twisted cycle play out all over
again it skitters in the dark its
insect-like legs tapping across the
marble floors as terrified Foundation
researchers flee they hear its voice the
Deep silky tones of an elderly British
man spouting nonsense likee the
nightmare is a dream to the nameless
slug that wanders across minefield the
remains of dear and Kings while the
scientists run the creature gains on
them it's fast impossibly fast while
they still try to escape down this
darkened hallway ear splitting
Containment Breach Sirens blast through
the air they may try to escape but it's
futile in a sense they're already dead
all they are now is pray for the heart
of darkness when someone says the word
heart there are a lot of images that
come to mind you might think of
Valentine's Day heart-shaped cards and
candies you might think of heartbreak
rejection loss you might simply think of
a heart in the anatomical sense the
vital organ that pumps blood through our
bodies it's unlikely though that you
would associate the word heart with
Terror destruction and countless deaths
however employees of the SCP Foundation
might think differently especially if
they've ever had a runin with SCP 0 58
much of the information about 0 58's
Discovery is highly classified but the
few details that are known paint a
chilling picture at an SCP Foundation
test site the day was proceeding as
usual with scientists and security
Personnel going about their regular
daily tasks there was no hint of danger
in the air beyond the base level that
always comes with setting foot in an SCP
Foundation site at least several
researchers were performing an
experiment the specifics of which which
have been expunged from all records
involving the carcass of a cow when a
researcher Dr C placed his hands on the
specimen and prepared to dissect it he
was shocked to feel a pulse coming from
the supposedly dead animal Dr C shared
his surprise with his colleagues but his
concerns were dismissed immediately
clearly this was a corpse he was
imagining things they said after all he
was relatively new to the job it was
probably just nerves the head researcher
Dr insisted that he take over pushing Dr
C to the side Dr L began to make an
incision into the animal's chest as he
did he too felt something peculiar there
was no doubt about it this dead cow had
a beating heart he looked up from his
work to tell the other researchers to
explain what he felt but by then it was
too late something horrible was already
happening with a stomach churning sound
of squishing flesh the cow's heart burst
from it chest and flopped onto the
flooor it was terrifyingly large and all
the doctors jumped back from the side of
it four spinley spider-like legs poked
through the Flesh of the heart and it
began to quickly skitter about the room
researchers reviewing the security
footage would later note that it didn't
just move randomly it seemed agitated
angry at being discovered and it
displayed immediate hostility towards
the scientists in the room four
tentacles next unfurled from within the
heart and stretched out into full
writhing appendages they move
frighteningly fast as the heart whipped
around the room and were coated in sharp
spines finally a stinger poked out from
the back of the heart where the hole of
the superior vava should be all of the
scientists leapt into action with one
reaching for a scalpel and another
moving towards the door but before the
men could so much as call for help the
tentacles wrapped around them and RI
them to shreds hearing screams coming
from the laboratory security personnel
arrived to contain the threat however
there were no match for the strange
creature that would soon be known as SCP
058 it tore through the security team in
minutes leaving their tattered remains
in its wake much to the horror of the
surviving Personnel at the site SCP 058
was able to escape containment and make
its way to a neighboring Town reports of
the incident said that when the creature
reached the town you could hear the
screaming for Miles SCP 058 they carved
a path of violence through the town
attacking everything in sight with its
stinger and tentacles and leaving a
trail of strange fluid from its stinger
dozens of citizens were killed and 70%
of the buildings were completely
destroyed when agents were dispatched to
the location to retrieve the creature
they were shocked to see the level of
Destruction caused by something so small
the scent of blood and smoke filled the
air and severed limbs littered the
ground alongside splintered wood and
collapsed brick the survivors removed
from the wreckage were inconsolable only
caling down once they were given an
amnestic to erase their memory of the
encounter with SCP 058 they had to be
given new lives as well as there was
nothing left of their old ones SCP
Foundation agents were only able to
capture and contain SCP 058 after it was
crushed by pieces of a building that
collapsed on top of it they found it
flattened under a slab of stone legs
flailing uselessly tentacles limp the
agents were able to safely remove the
debris and bring in the heart without
any more casualties that day once it was
brought into captivity the heart was
contained for 3 weeks and remained
largely quiet during that time it was
almost inconceivable that this small
creature hadn't been killed in the
incident but the foundation would soon
learn that this creature was freakishly
durable it escaped once more while being
transferred to an SCP Containment site
again causing injuries and death having
only experienced SCP 058 in its docile
injured form the team responsible for
the transfer was unprepared for the
sheer power and violence the creature
was capable of it was able to escape an
armored car and make its way into a
forest where it eviscerated several
squirrels and rabbits or rather they
were believed to be squirrels and
rabbits the remains were too mutilated
to properly identify it was only finally
apprehended after being CR CR by an
armored tank but even this didn't kill
the creature and it was transferred to
Armed biocontainment Area 14 where it
remains to this day there is a great
deal about SCP 058 that is horrifying
but there is one attribute it has shown
in captivity that would make even the
most seasoned researchers skin crawl
though it has no anatomical capacity for
speech no throat vocal cords or even a
respiratory system SCP 058 SP
not only does it speak but it speaks
constantly in the deep voice of an
elderly British man no one knows who the
voice might belong to or if it belongs
to anyone at all perhaps it belongs only
to SCP 058 somehow as is often the case
with scps that are capable of speech
there have been multiple attempts to
interview the creature and each time it
ended in complete disaster the only
interview with an available transcript
interview 05 804 was conducted by Dr
Johnston with several Personnel in the
room for additional security Dr Johnston
attempted to get out the origins of the
creature asking for its name and where
it was from the creature responded in
cryptic unsettling poetry giving answers
to simple questions with I had dreams of
the queen Wonders that lived inside the
hearts of love and silent treatments for
all the elderly that I knew were once
whole after the for recitation of a
similar verse from the heart Personnel D
067 made a comment on the creepy nature
of its responses almost as if it was
offended by the remark SCP 058
immediately stretched a tentacle across
the room wrapped it around D 067 and
lifted him into the air he began
screaming and clawing at the tentacle in
an attempt to free himself as his fellow
personel tried to help him they grabbed
at the tentacle but found their hands
pierced and bloodied by the spikes that
cover it Dr Johnston commanded 058 to
let him go but it did not oblige instead
the man was crushed to death by the
tentacle and his limp body left to drop
to the floor the interview concluded
with a single statement from the
nightmarish heart the sensual violence
of lust is all the Assurance you will
ever need to know the worth of Life ASP
058 never seems to say anything that has
to do with the people or events around
it it speaks in the same haunting poetic
language even when it's attacking or
killing something no matter what happens
to it what is done to it or what anyone
says SCP 058 keeps talking and its tone
of voice with the pace of speech never
changing and further attempts to
interview it have been abandoned due to
the safety risk involved so what
happened to the creature often called
The Heart of Darkness where is it now
SCP 058 is kept in an isolated
containment chamber made of reinforced
heat resistant steel with a backing of
reinforced Concrete in order to Plate
its bloodthirsty carnivorous Tendencies
the creature is given a live cow every 3
days it is uncertain how exactly SCP 058
eats given that it does not have a mouth
or stomach but every time it is finished
with a cow only bones remain routine
maintenance is conducted on a tight
schedule and the heart is never allowed
out of its containment area under any
circumstances after two previous escapes
from containment the foundation is not
taking any chances its constant speech
is recorded via audio devices that are
running at all times out of concern for
their safety and mental health no
Personnel are permitted to listen to
recordings of SCP 058 speaking for more
than 30 minutes at a time it is unknown
what will happen to someone who listens
for longer but it has been suggested
that the consequences could be dire if
the creature ever escapes again the
containment site is ordered to be
destroyed via the detonation of an
on-site nuclear weapon under no
circumstances can it be allowed to make
its way out into the world again even
with all these precautions in place SCP
058 has been responsible for over 150
deaths at its current containment site
there are some at the foundation who
have campaigned for SCP 058 to be
terminated believing that there is more
harm than good done by keeping it alive
however all ATT attempts to terminate it
have so far failed no matter how much
physical trauma the heart suffers it
does not seem to be able to be killed it
can only be incapacitated for a short
time there was a classic Horror Story by
Edgar Allen Poe called The Telltale
Heart in it a man murders an old man and
buries his body beneath the floorboards
of his home there even though the old
man is certainly dead the murderer
swears he can hear the beating of the
heart coming up through the floorboards
no matter what does to quiet the sound
he cannot Escape it and is eventually
driven mad by the incessant beating of
the dead man's heart SCP 058 may not be
a man's heart a human heart or even a
real heart at all however just like The
Telltale Heart it continues to
impossibly beat no matter how hard
anyone tries to stop it the steady thump
of its pulse haunts the SCP Foundation a
grim reminder that there is something
within its walls that can and will will
kill everyone it can if given the chance
it couldn't be destroyed by collapsed
buildings an armored tank or an army of
experts and the contingency plan of a
nuclear blast is not even guaranteed to
work it is entirely possible that once
the facility has been laid waste and all
the staff have been incinerated and the
smoke has finally cleared the Heart of
Darkness will still be there still
beating still talking and still still
killing it all started in 1983 with
reports of human trafficking in the
heart of Sin City the FBI had gotten
word of a potential trafficking ring
operating out of an abandoned department
store in Las Vegas Nevada and
immediately began organizing a secret
raid on the building while they would
indeed encounter something horrifying
within that abandoned Apartment Store it
wasn't criminals or human trafficking in
fact it wasn't human at all this is the
horrifying story of SCP 847 after weeks
of planning the raid on the department
store was conducted in the dead of night
agents covered all the exits and
entrances and a helicopter was stationed
nearby in case anyone attempted to run
it should have been a perfect trap but
things never go as planned when you
don't know what you're dealing with the
agents breached the door and began
searching the darkened building it
didn't appear that there was any power
so the traffickers must have had great
night vision in a high to an for creepy
locals agents soon heard a faint humming
sound coming from below a generator it
must be located in the basement and be
the Hub of this criminal Enterprise
readying themselves for whatever they
were about to find the agents descended
into the basement as they moved deeper
into the building they found that
lighting rigs had been set up they must
be getting closer to something but that
something was still a mystery a senior
FBI special agent was leading the charge
his pistol drawn and and ready it was
quiet too quiet did the traffickers
already realize they were coming and
clear out he was ready to consider this
bus to bust when he heard a quiet muing
in the distance a persistent whining
whimper that was
undeniably human he gave the signal to
his fellow agents to follow the noise
they proceeded forward towards the pain
sounds and found themselves in a wide
well-lit room filled with department
store mannequins all were broken to some
degree some were totally smashed to
Pieces some were chained to walls and
locked in cages others were wrapped in
plastic the agent wondered whether this
was some kind of Twisted joke or a
messed up avanguard art piece that's
when he noticed her a single Crouch
figure in the distance hunched over and
whimpering in a darkened corner of the
room near a fulllength mirror he
couldn't fully make her out but he got
the sense that something was wrong she
was injured bent over was she even
missing an arm just what have these
monsters done to this woman he whispered
a request for backup Into His Radio and
pushed on when he got within 50 m of
this strange woman her demeanor changed
entirely she jerked around her movements
forced erratic and painful looking the
woman stared directly into the agent's
eyes and began hobbling towards him
occasionally stopping to strike a pose
as if modeling during a photo shoot just
then the agent made a horrifying
realization this thing moving towards
them was was n a woman at all it was a
living mannequin as she got closer
though he realized that the mannequin's
broken left forearm had been carved into
a large shiv a female Junior FBI agent
had been one of the many to pour into
the room when the raid leader had
radioed for backup the second she
entered the 50 m range of this strange
mannequin everything changed in an
instant its eyes and mouth began
dripping with a thick viscous resin its
whimpering gasps suddenly became vicious
earsplitting screeches and it turned its
gaze from the senior FBI agent it was
now focused on the junior agent who had
just entered the room and broke into a
terrifying run straight towards her the
mannequin moved with a violent
single-minded purpose other agents began
firing but it was running freakishly
fast and easily dodged most of the
bullets the few that actually hit seemed
to do nothing to slow the creature down
it Shrugged off the damage and kept
running with a great leap at landed on
the terrified Junior agent and began
jabbing her with its bladed arm the
other agents stopped firing fearing they
might accidentally hit their colleague
during the Panic the mannequin was
ruthless clawing and stabbing with the
strange resin leaking out of its every
orifice terrified and unable to reach
her gun the agent remembered her
training she reached into her belt and
grabbed her stun gun jamming the two
probes up against the creature's chest
and giving it 30,000 volts the creature
spasmed fell backward Wards and
collapsed in a heap on the ground Frozen
this was the first recorded encounter
with SCP 847 a violent living mannequin
with a serious problem with women this
terrifying report was passed up the
chain of command until it landed on the
desk of a foundation agent working in
the FBI the foundation quickly swooped
in and claimed the mannequin delivered
necessary amnestic treatment to all
who'd witnessed it and closely observed
the female Junior FBI agent's recovery
in a private Hospital with Foundation
ties as it turns out they were right to
do so as the junior agent was in for a
gruesome fate while the wound she'
suffered at the hands of SCP 847 didn't
appear fatal the fact that the
mannequin's anomalous resin excretions
entered the open wound changed
everything several hours after being
committed the junior agent began
complaining of limb stiffness and
difficulty moving this quickly developed
into full paralysis over time her skin
and internal or organs began to harden
until the process dub plastination came
to a gruesome end the junior agent
wasn't just dead she had been
transformed into a mannequin Foundation
researchers were met with a truly
horrifying realization this means that
all the other Broken Mannequins found
with SCP 847 were likely once living
humans attacked and transformed by the
anomaly now a source for new harvested
body parts now safe interred at a
foundation containment facility though
the real tests on SCP 847 to determine
its behavior and physical attributes
could begin the most important detail
about SCP 847 is that its aggression is
exclusively directed towards women as
opposed to when it encounters men and
its instincts are more self-destructive
through a series of tests and
observations researchers have been able
to pin down three different distinct
patterns of behavior for SC P 847
pattern Z behaviors occur when there are
no humans standing within 50 m of SCP
847 the mannequin will seek out a ful
length mirror and pose in front of it
much like a department store mannequin
attempting to show off its clothes it
remains largely inanimate during these
periods and will very occasionally use a
finger or whatever appendage is
available given its habit for
self-mutilation to scratch messages on
nearby surfaces patterned y Behavior
occurs when male humans with XY
chromosomes enter a 50 m radius around
SCP 847 just like its reaction to the
male FBI agents who found it 847 will
initially emit vocalizations that seem
like whimpering gasps before making eye
contact and striking provocative poses
while approaching the subject it will
then remain static and allow the male
subject to pose its body however after
the male subject leaves the area 847
will enter a state of considerable the
stress and begin removing or shattering
parts of its body the foundation has
found that the parts removed or
shattered are often consistent with
parts that the male subjects found
displeasing during interactions showing
a masochistic desire to impress these
parts are then harvested back from
plastinated victims which brings us to
the most dangerous of Its Behavior
patterns pattern X behaviors occur when
female humans enter a 50 m radius around
the creature 847 will immediately become
brutally aggressive switching its noises
from whimpers to violent screeches and
growls 847 experiences enhanced physical
capabilities during pattern X states its
speed has been measured at 45 kmph
making it as fast as the legendary SCP
096 it's also been shown to exhibit
extreme physical strength it's during
this pattern of behavior that it begins
excreting its deadly resin which has
been proven to only be dangerous to
women in these states the only thing
capable of reliably pacifying the being
is a powerful electric shock the shock
causes the creatur's resin to harden
temporarily incapacitating it for
roughly 5 minutes other Conventional
Weapons and damage has no meaningful
effect on SCP 847 after a number of
incidents that had sad and violent
endings the foundation Ethics Committee
forbade the use of female d-class
Personnel in SCP 847 testing when it
came to female subjects 847 always
slipped into a state of extreme
aggression so instead the foundation
began testing with male subjects in
hopes of better understanding the
Dynamics between human males and SCP 847
various misogynistic d-class males were
introduced into the containment chamber
which was modeled to look like a bedroom
for the purposes of Behavioral study
each one either during or after their
interaction with SCP 847 was told to
comment on some aspect they felt
dissatisfied with the mannequin
shattered its own chest after hearing it
described as being out of proportion
after another d-class called its nose
ugly the mannequin broke it off after
another said that its hair was out of
fashion and commented on its inability
to drink it tore out its hair and liver
all parts were replaced after the
experiments things took their most
violent and upsetting turn yet with the
introduction of D
7294 A lot of the time declass Personnel
are considered to be as Anonymous as
they are expendable but
d729 4 is an exception before becoming
d-class he was a successful cello
teacher who brutally murdered one of his
teenage students and her mother he's
typically employed in tests when the
foundation wishes to see interactions
between anomalies and humans with
confirmed Psychopathic personalities
during his interaction with SCP 847 he
belittled and humiliated the mannequin
he forced it into uncomfortable poses
and even snapped off one of its fingers
before being dragged from the room by
Foundation guards in the following
debrief he further bared the mannequin
as useless and lousy at its job of being
controlled by him in response 847
extracted its own brains eyes and
clavicle before shattering its own hands
in dismay so why does 847 behave this
way while it may appear monstrous it
seems that the reason SCP 847 does what
it does is All Too Human it hurts women
because it itself is hurting and it's
willing to hurt itself even more for the
approval of the objects of its desire as
a result it's an anomaly trapped in an
endless cycle of pain and violence
perhaps one day it'll be able to free
itself from the loop but that day is
unlikely to come for this murderous
mannequin anytime soon the year was 1983
and 7-year-old Andrea Bradbury was
wandering the streets of of Nashville
Tennessee one of her favorite activities
was to head down to the local movie
theater and fantasize about the movie
she'd one day be old enough to see this
fateful weekend Andrea's local theater
was playing a brand new release jaws 3D
what she didn't know is that this simple
innocent activity would bring little
Andrea into dangerous contact with SCP
178 and change her life forever jaws 3D
isn't exactly a classic it was one of
the many for sequels pumped out to cash
in on the 3D craze of the early 1980s
people paid extra for the privilege of
sitting in the dark with an
uncomfortable pair of cardboard glasses
while cheesy effects leapt out of the
screen towards them many of the movie
goers simply threw away the cheap
disposable glasses as soon as they left
the theater leaving them scattered on
the sidewalk outside seeing a pair of 3D
glasses on the ground right there for
the taking was the highlight of little
Andrea's week she may not have been old
enough to see any of the movies but she
knew that a local shop sold books with
images that popped out of the page with
a simple pair of 3D glasses excited by
the prospect of getting to experience 3D
Andrea grabbed a pair of glasses and ran
straight for the bookstore later that
night she was in her bedroom with a
stereoscopic image of a ferris wheel
Andrea adjusted the glasses and the
ferris wheel really did pop right off
the page she marveled at the image
coming out of the book and felt like she
could almost touch it but suddenly a
strange feeling came over her she had
the feeling that she wasn't alone still
wearing the glasses Andrea looked up
from her book and saw it standing in the
corner of her room something huge
something
monstrous Andrea's parents heard her
scream and came rushing into her room
there was their little girl dead it
looked like she'd been mauled to death
by a wild animal but there was no sign
of her killer the wind windows were shut
tight unable to be opened from the
outside it was like whatever horrible
creature had done this had vanished Into
Thin Air the coroner's report didn't
give any other Clues as to who could
have done this except that whoever or
whatever had murdered her it appeared to
have three long and Incredibly sharp
claws the terrible tragedy of Andrea's
death rocked Nashville but it never made
the national papers why because the SCP
Foundation was immediately on the case
undercover agents in the US fish and
wildlife service flagged the strange
death as anomalous and SCP field
Personnel arrived to do their own
investigation of the crime scene there
they quickly discovered Andrea's 3D
glasses which would eventually be
classified as SCP
178 an agent looked over the glasses
there didn't seem to be anything out of
the ordinary about them just your
regular cardboard frames with blue and
red tinted film over the eyes everything
about them seemed normal so he tried
tried the glasses on for himself he
picked up the open book off the ground
where Andrea had likely dropped it and
saw the ferris wheel pop off the page
nothing abnormal until he turned his
head slightly he saw the head of some
kind of thing only an inch away from his
own looking over his shoulder at the
book being a trained SCP agent he
maintained his composure and looked
around the room as he did he saw that
several other creatures were standing
and watching none of the rest of the
recovery team seemed to notice the
creatures and when the agent removed SCP
178 they vanished it appeared they had
found whatever had caused Andrea
Bradbury's death the glasses were
immediately taken to the nearest
Foundation containment site for further
testing seeing these mysterious entities
through SCP 178 may have answered one
question but it raised many others what
are these creatures were they real or
merely Illusions created by SCP
178 if they are real are they somehow
summoned by SCP 178 or simply revealed
by them there was already one death that
could be tied to the glasses with some
certainty but just how dangerous were
they the SCP Foundation was about to
find out Foundation scientists devised a
series of experiments with a test
chamber separated from an adjoining
observation chamber by a panel of
reinforced bulletproof glass a member of
d-class personnel was placed into the
test chamber along with SCP 178 he was
instructed to put on the glasses and
report back what he saw to the
researchers the d-class followed the
orders however when he did so he quickly
entered a state of extreme distress he
threw away the glasses and covered his
eyes screaming wildly when ordered to
compose himself and explain what he saw
under threat of termination the d-class
described a hideous creature standing
close to his face watching when asked to
elaborate he described it as having too
many eyes after that the d-class refused
to put the glasses back on again despite
direct orders and threats from
Foundation staff he was then removed
from the test chamber and observed
although he experienced 2 days of mild
paranoia after 30 total days of
observation the d-class was found to
have no lasting psychological effects
disappointed by the meager results of
the first test the researchers had at
least confirm that they did have an
anomalous object in their possession and
pressed on with experimentation they
used the same methodology again on
another d-class she was placed into the
chamber and instructed to put on SCP 178
then described The Entity she saw in
great detail when she put on the glasses
she recoiled in horror at the monster
she saw staring back at her she said
that the creature was tall and bipedal
with two additional upper appendages
ending in large conical protrusions she
also described the creature's head as
being smooth when asked if the creature
exhibited any any kind of aggression or
hostility she said that it was
completely still it was just standing
there after a few minutes though the
creatur seemed to lose interest and
begin staring at the wall the
researchers were happy to learn more
about the creatur's physicality but they
still weren't confident that it wasn't
just an illusion created by the glasses
they needed to engineer an interaction
for the next experiment they decided to
alter the particulars a fractal blue and
red image in a similar style to the
stereoscopic Ferris wheel from the book
Andrea had purchased was fixed to one
wall against the opposite wall they
placed a bucket containing 10 standard
tennis balls this time the d-class a
convicted murderer and arsonist was told
he was helping to test a new 3D
augmented reality project the entities
he would see as far as he knew were
little more than digital projections
though when he actually wore SCP 178 and
saw them he commented that whoever
designed them must be crazy the
researchers instructed the declass to
pick up a tennis ball and throw it at
one of the entities the second he did so
deep lacerations began appearing all
over his body the onslaught was brutal
and quick and the d-class was dead soon
after that this confirmed to the
researchers that the creatures did seem
to have some level of tangible presence
and they could be extremely violent if
provoked next they wished to see if it
was possible to have any kind of
interaction with the creatures without
it immediately descending into violence
to test this Theory the researchers
brought a 19-year-old d-class into the
testing chamber under the same pretense
of testing new 3D
technology much like the others she was
still horrified by the appearance of the
creatures but was calmed down by the
researchers they asked her to speak to
the creatures directly without
exhibiting any kind of aggression she
said hello weird thing how are you today
in a somewhat bored voice and this was
all it took to sign her death warrant
she was immediately complely slashed to
death by invisible creatures the results
seemed clear any interaction whatsoever
with the creatures while wearing SCP 178
was a death sentence like a slightly
more outgoing shy guy but the
researchers would soon find that this
anomaly had even more
surprises for their next test they
brought in two subjects one would wear
SCP 178 and dictate to the other how
they should interact with the creature
they could not see the results of this
experiment were bloody yet in
informative both subjects were slashed
to death when the unseeing d-class
interacted with one of the creatures on
her companion's instructions it appeared
that anyone with sufficient knowledge of
the creatures who attempts to interact
with them is doomed even if they can't
directly see one of them it was an
upsetting realization for the
researchers SCP 178 may be much more
dangerous than they initially imagined
and what they learn in the next
experiment was even worse they adopted
the same methodology as the last for the
following experiment two subjects one
seeing and the other interacting however
this time as soon as subject number one
put on the glasses they knew that
something was terribly wrong he began
panicking stating that the entire
chamber was full of the creatures all
standing and watching the researchers
undertook these experiments knowing that
they didn't often turn out well for the
d-class so they didn't seem too worried
about this new development that is until
the subject stated that they could see
three more of the creatures
and they weren't in the test chamber
they were in the observation room in
fact one of them was looking right over
one of the three researchers shoulders
immediately the researchers lost
composure and began to panic they were
used to putting d-class in danger that
was part of the job but they weren't
prepared for this in just moments the
observation room became a bloodbath as
the three researchers who'd been
designing and Performing all the
experiments were Torn to Pieces by
creatures they couldn't see SCP 178 had
gone from being one of the more innocent
looking anomalies to one of the most
mysterious and deadly the creatures seem
to be powerful violent and Incredibly
numerous the fact that they can only be
observed through 178 stereoscopic lenses
and kill anyone who even attempts to
interact with them makes them almost
impossible to understand it was always a
tragedy when the foundation lost good
researchers but the work must continue
and the experiments were soon restarted
with increased safety measures
of course those didn't do much good and
after another disastrous experiment that
resulted in the whole sector getting
locked down all research into SCP 178
was placed under increased scrutiny they
needed to find some way of observing the
creatures without the risk of having to
share space with them the proposed
solution was seeing if the SCP 178
glasses were compatible with camera
technology for remote viewing much like
all stereoscopic glasses they found that
looking through only one lens at a time
was ineffective the solution was
relatively simple a dual lens camera in
a roughly similar configuration to human
eyes this however didn't give them the
Comfort or the answers they hoped for
researchers commented upon finally
seeing the creatures that they were even
more hideous than they'd ever imagined
as they observed a victim interacting
with the creatures via their new camera
they found that as soon as the creatures
were interacted with in any way they
would grow three Long Claws and attack
and they were as fast just as they were
ferocious from the observations there
were only a few things that the
foundation now knew about them for sure
their physical appearance their violent
nature their enhanced physical abilities
and the fact they appear to be pretty
much everywhere and who knows how long
they'd been here observing us humans
while we glided by them ignorant to
their presence it's enough to make you
think twice before putting on a pair of
3D glasses again but of course never
putting on the glasses doesn't mean
you're s safe just knowing about them
puts you in danger they could be
standing next to you right now looking
over your shoulder as you watch this
video just remember if you want to be
safe you can't ever let them know you're
aware after all just because you can't
see something doesn't mean it can't hurt
you you've finally done it after years
of adding movies and shows to your cues
you've officially run out of things to
watch on Netflix
you've also exhausted your entire
backlog of books and you've even run out
of cereal boxes to read so you're left
roaming the streets in search of
entertainment that's when you see a worn
looking flyer stapled to a nearby
telephone pole it's an ad for local
community theater production of a play
you've never heard of a play called the
hanged King's tragedy normally you
wouldn't think of yourself as much of a
theater person but something about the
art on the poster grabs you there's a
strange figure on the poster its face
shrouded its body wrapped in a web of
chains your curiosity gets the better of
you and you check the performance date
to your pleasant surprise opening night
is a week from now and you don't have
anything planned you've made up your
mind you're going to attend a live
performance of the hanged King's tragedy
it's going to be the first live play
you've ever seen and little do you know
it may also be the last
because the Hang Kings tragedy isn't
just any old play it's a powerful and
deadly mimetic Hazard that may be one of
the gateways to an even more dangerous
being it's known to the SCP Foundation
as SCP 701 so take your seats be sure to
read your programs thoroughly and
prepare for the dark and terrifying tale
of the hanged King's tragedy and the
wave of death and destruction it causes
in its theatrical wake but how could you
know any of this while you head home to
make dinner looking forward to seeing
the new plane next week the local
thespians are hard at work performing
dress rehearsals the director one Marcus
Fitch happened upon a copy of the play
while looking for Carolinian theater
that's a little more familyfriendly than
some of the Shakespearean Classics when
he'd first discovered the hanged King's
tragedy on a theatrical Forum it was
described as being similar to
Shakespeare's hand let and Titus
andronicus but the violence was largely
offstage and implied with a lot of the
play's nastier elements glossed over
perfect for audience of all ages given
the fact that performances of the Hang
Kings tragedy tend to be mass casualty
events for reasons you'll soon see the
foundation does everything they can to
control the spread of the plays script
all copies are kept in a tripl locked
vault in a secure Foundation archive
which currently includes two copies iies
of the original publication that are
dated to the year 1640 27 copies of the
1965 trade paperback edition 10 copies
of a 1971 hard cover printing 21 floppy
discat containing the place script and
one svhs video cassette tape containing
a live taping of one particularly
Infamous incident however this seemingly
does little to prevent new performances
of the hanged King's tragedy from
occurring the text of the play
continually pops up online often under
different or misspelled titles
preventing Foundation web crawlers from
keeping track of them all nevertheless
the foundation does everything in its
power to detect and stop performances
before they can go ahead the danger of
putting on or even viewing a performance
of The Hang Kings tragedy cannot be
overstated it's believed that in the
almost 300 years since its original
publication it's claimed 10,000 lives
through performances at the very least
and if you're an attendance dying
quickly is one of the better outcomes
the origins of this mimic virus are just
as mysterious as the power that seems to
drive its effects the play Never Had A
declared author and the publisher one
William Cook disappeared from all
historical records after the plays
Publications performances have been
varied over the 300 years the play has
been active it's been spotted everywhere
from British University drama troops to
American High School plays in what could
have been an even more disastrous
tragedy a television adaptation of the
play was almost broadcast by the BBC
before the foundation stepped in and put
a stop to it while its containment
classification is currently ID
scientists who have studied the play
have campaigned strongly to upgrade the
Hang King's tragedy to ker class on
account of its unpredictability and
tendency to manifest across the globe
with incidences appearing decades apart
while members of the 05 Council are
skeptical some researchers even believe
that given a wide enough exposure the H
Kings tragedy could cause a dreaded XK
Class end of the world scenario it is
that dangerous at this point you're
probably wondering what exactly is the H
King's tragedy what's the play even
about as the name suggests the play is a
tragedy and takes place over five acts
during the Carolinian era portraying the
drama of the Royal Court much like a
number of plays from that time did it
takes place in the city of cako the
capital of the mysterious fictional
Kingdom of trinko the focal point of the
play is the conflict between Gonzalo the
illegitimate king of trinko and Antonio
the true heir to the throne before the
start of the play the previous king of
trulo King seph Forza had been betrayed
and murdered by Gonzalo Gonzalo LED seph
Forza into the woods where he and his
men subdued the king and hanged him from
a nearby tree like a common criminal
hence the hanged King's tragedy however
Gonzalo is trying to keep his part in
the king's murder a secret to keep the
throne for himself but his
guilt-stricken wife Isabella threatens
to Spill The Secret of Sephora's murder
while Antonio tries to uncover the truth
of what happened in the woods Gonzalo in
true Shakespearean villain style plots
further murders of his co-conspirators
and loose ends to keep his Dark Secret
safe this is where the play gets a
little gruesome one enemy Gonzalo had
killed and cooked into a stew he then
intends to use the stew to murder his
entire court with the help of an
effective and undetectable poison he was
given by the mysterious ambassador of
alagada though you'll be pleased to know
that this tragedy has somewhat of a
happy ending in the end Gonzalo is
exposed and Antonio claims his rightful
place as king of trulo unlike his
predecessor Antonio decides to show
mercy and Gonzalo is exiled to a
monastery for life rather than being
executed for his murderous ways the
heroes are rewarded the villains are
punished and all the deserving parties
live happily ever after at face value
nothing seems off about the play if
you're familiar with other works of the
era you might even find yourself getting
bored while reading it how can something
this normal be the curse play that
claims so many thousand thousands of
lives but this plays unassuming nature
only serves to make it more dangerous it
doesn't appear that the mimetic hazard
is caused by simply reading the play
like all good theater it only truly
comes to life on stage and your local
production of the H Kings tragedy is no
exception as your community's amateur
actors study and rehearse the play
making sure to commit every scene every
line every single word to memory they
don't notice the little things that to
an outsider might seem a little off
occasionally during group dress
rehearsals actors will Veer from the
script and we're not talking about flub
lines or simple improvisation no actors
will at times seem like they're reading
from a completely different script and
their fellow performers will respond in
kind the play lulls you into a false
sense of security stay Chan crew members
even the director all believe they're
performing the play exactly as it was
originally written okay so that's not so
bad a play that changes itself but
things are going to get worse from this
point much much worse but hey why let a
deadly anomaly ruin your evening plans
you've been looking forward to seeing
this play all week and you couldn't seem
to get that figure from the poster out
of your mind you have no idea that this
entity is wanted by the SCP Foundation
and that its designation is SCP 7
01-1 all you want is an unforgettable
theater experience and you will
certainly get one it's a packed house
not an empty seat in sight the house
lights dim and the curtain opens act one
is quite normal with all the
backstabbing and Royal Court Intrigue
you'd expect you actually feel yourself
getting a little bored a big yawn
escapes your mouth you're thinking that
maybe this was a big mistake and you
might sneak out between Acts
when just then you see it in the final
scene of act one you see the shrouded
figure lingering in the background
against the curtains he seems so still
he's almost like a shadow but as each
Act seems to run into the next he
becomes more prominent the rest of the
cast Never acknowledges him as they
deliver dramatic monologues but he's
always there finally the play reached
Act five the Grand Banquet scene where
where it all comes to head Gonzalo is
preparing to poison his dinner guest
with his cannibal stew while Antonio and
his allies plot to reveal his terrible
crimes and Dethrone him you find
yourself so gripped by the drama of it
all you almost didn't notice that the
shrouded figure of SCP 71-1 was standing
right among the actors now while
unbeknownst to you the actors have been
deviating from the scripted story this
whole time things are about to really
take a turn for the horrific SCP
71-1 who is now known to the other
performers as the hanged King produces a
blade from thin air and passes it to the
actor playing gonzalo's wife the actors
on stage suddenly become entranced they
attack and restrain Gonzalo and a news
drops down from somewhere above the
stage the actors proceed to
ritualistically hang Gonzalo before the
actor playing his wife stabs him to
death all while chanting blood for the
hanged King you should be horrified but
you're not you don't even feel like
yourself anymore and you're loving
everything that's happening on stage a
series of other nooses fall from above
each actor grabs their own noose and the
cast repeats blood for the hanged King
before sacrificing their lives to the
Shroud wearing monster if the Carnage
stopped there it would be bad enough but
this play doesn't just drive its players
to acts of violent Insanity it pulls in
the audience too before you know it
you're pulled into a vicious brawl with
your fellow theater goers there's biting
clawing punching people hitting each
other with chairs like it's a wrestling
cage match it's such a frenzy of random
senseless violence that the building
can't contain it anymore you and anyone
else who isn't dead already Spilled Out
onto the streets and start attacking
everyone you can get your hands on it's
transformed from a pleasant night out at
the theater into a full-blown riot even
the police sent in to control the
situation are overwhelmed it isn't until
the SCP Foundation sends a number of
mobile task forces trained in advanced
crowd control that the situation finally
begins to deescalate but you don't care
even when large men in Foundation
tactical gear are holding your arms you
still try to bite and kick the effects
of the play normally wear off after
around 24 hours but until then the
infected including you are just rage
fueled monsters in the end it takes four
adult men to properly restrain you
you'll feel the bruises from their night
sticks tomorrow but now all you feel is
hate and violence and a single-minded
Devotion to something out there that you
couldn't possibly comprehend and the
whole time you're screaming one thing
over and over again blood for the hanged
King Norse mythology tells the story of
yorong Gand a Great Serpent so long that
it wraps itself the entire way around
midgard and bites its own taale Legend
says that when yorong Gund unclasps its
jaws and starts to unfurl it will signal
the beginning of Ragnarok the
destruction of the world and that was
about as much information as the
foundation gave to agent neelen when
they assigned him to his watch Duty in
Greenland in the frozen tundra all day
every day he had been equipped with a
sniper rifle thermal goggles and put up
high in a watchtower if he saw anyone
anyone he had to shoot on sight no
questions asked whether it was his
squadmates the brigadier general or even
his own mother if anyone walked across
the barren stretch of ice ahead of him
he was to shoot them dead under no
circumstances was anyone allowed to
enter that cave the fate of the world
could depend on it but it was cold and
the days were long for months he'd been
sitting there by himself without seeing
a single soul walk across the glacier
that's why it took him so long to spy
the figure stumbling across the ice half
a kilometer away but the person didn't
look any clearer when agent neelon took
a look through his thermal binoculars
barely registering as much warmer than
the snow around him the man stumbled
forward seemingly unaware of the world
around him could this be the start of
the Swan Song of the world is this what
he had been warned about without a
moment's hesitation agent neelson
snatched up the sniper rifle and readied
his sights on the man somewhere buried
deep beneath the Greenland ice is one of
the most dangerous scps that the
foundation has ever come across to say
that SCP 722s Reawakening could spell
the destruction of human civilization is
no Idol concern classified as a ker
level SCP SCP 722 has been nicknamed
yorong after the Norse myth researchers
speculate that the creatur's existence
could in some way be linked to the early
origins of the story of the Norse
creature 722 was brought to the
foundation's attention relatively
recently environmental activist group
Greenpeace was shooting a documentary on
the effects of global warming on
glaciers in Greenland a small crew
including a director producer three
camera operators and a sound recordist
headed out to get some close-up footage
from amongst the glaciers walking from
ice sheet to ice sheet they noticed
several rounded entrances to what looked
like deep Ice Caves surmising that these
open ings were only accessible to them
because of the melting Glacier Ice the
crew climbed down into the caves to get
some neverbe seen footage some of the
footage of their exploration has been
recovered since and in the background of
several shots as they are adjusting
exposure and pulling Focus you can hear
the producer and director theorizing
about where these caves have come from
they initially seem to think that the
caves are Millennia old preserved by
Sub-Zero temperatures but soon they come
across several markings on the walls
ancient hieroglyphs and symbols none of
the crew were language experts and so in
the footage you can hear them struggling
to identify which people group would
have carved those into the ice walls in
the decades since language experts from
around the world have studied these
markings on those walls and have still
been unable to identify any discernable
links to any known human script most
agree that it does seem to predate the
settlement of the island by Eric the Red
at the start of the 11th century during
this period it is believed that there
were no human settlements on the island
so the origins of this script remain
unknown as the footage goes on you may
start to notice something that the Green
Peace crew does not one of the ice walls
is no longer a wall at all it looks like
a rock in some of the footage but
whenever a flashlight Shines on its
surface you can see a pattern to it
scales then an opening at the far side
of the tunnel the crew emerges into an
enormous Cavern estimated to be upwards
of 200 m in height and several times
wider
even their powerful flashlights struggle
to cut through the darkness inside
that's the point that the sound
recorders notic is the scales running
alongside them as the camera pans you
see that they have been walking
alongside a tail several times taller
than them a tail that snakes its way
through the darkness of the cavern to
meet a hulking mass at the other side
shrouded in darkness that is where the
footage cuts off those green peace
filmmakers were next seen in a local
town that evening none of them had the
chance to extol the wonders of what
they'd encountered that day as they were
all sick a couple went straight to bed
in their lodgings complaining of intense
headaches and exhaustion others tried to
check themselves into the ER but never
made it each of the crew died of
different causes necrosis of the skin
internal bleeding kidney failure by 9:00
p.m. that day all of them were dead
fortunately there just so happened to be
a low-level Foundation agent staying in
the same guest house as as them who
heard the commotion within 2 days a
perimeter was established within 2 years
the foundation gained the bulk of
knowledge of this SCP that they rely on
to this day it is unknown exactly how
large SCP 722 actually is a hulking
serpent half buried in ice much of its
body cannot be observed it sleeps coiled
up in the middle of the cavern that the
filmmakers happened across some of its
body is buried beneath fallen in parts
of the caves others frozen into the
ground around it however based on what
can be observed of this SCP it is
estimated to be in the ranges of 8 to 12
km from head to tail fortunately for
just about everyone including you this
SCP appears to be dormant at no time
since its Discovery has this SCP been
observed to move make a sound or
otherwise indicate Consciousness sensors
are installed in the chamber to monitor
its life functions and study its heart
rate temperature brain activity and more
one concern to the foundation is that
since its Discovery 722 has had a 9%
uptick in neural activity researchers
hope that this is just a natural part of
the sleep cycle and that it will return
to a deeper Slumber soon that is the
hope at least so what makes this SCP so
dangerous then if it's sound asleep well
let's go back to agent neelon steering
through the scope of his rifle the
barrel kicked back a puff of warm smoke
there and gone and cold there he watched
just long enough to confirm the kill
before radioing back to command what he
had observed within an hour the cleanup
crew arrived riding on snowmobiles they
waited at a distance for an hour before
approaching the body rather
unceremoniously they wrapped it up in a
black plastic bag strapped it to the
back of their snowmobile and took it
away for cremation neelen just sat there
in his Watchtower the whole time
observing it all the person looked sick
and not the kind of sick that you'd get
from spending too much time out there on
the ice their skin had gone rotten like
they had gang grein or leprosy it wasn't
just your usual frostbite most
concerning they'd been wearing a
jumpsuit standard issue for d-class
personnel only a vial held in their cold
dead fingers was any kind of clue for
neelen as to what had been going on in
that cave but that was as close as the
agent ever came to understanding the
mysteries of SCP 722 the vial however
was in many ways all he needed to know
that is because contained in that vial
was a sample of the liquid secreted by
722 it is a liquid that the Green Piece
crew came into close contact with when
they found the creature and it's a
liquid that promises and denies great
power and great risk to the foundation
any and all attempts to study this
liquid in any meaningful sense have
failed anyone who comes into contact
with it will immediately suffer acute
sickness interestingly however there
seems to be little consistency as to how
how this sickness manifests itself some
develop a number of cancerous cells
whilst others lose cognitive function
due to brain swelling symptoms seem to
vary from person to person naturally
this makes studying the substance very
difficult hazardous material suits have
been deployed for researchers attempting
to study it but have all failed despite
being otherwise effective against
chemical biological and radioactive
threats how the substance is able to
infect them is unknown sadly a good
number of scientists s had to die to
make this discovery another route of
study is to take the substance out of
the cave and observe it under laboratory
conditions this was what agent neelon
observed as he shot and killed the
d-class Personnel emerging from the Cave
the d-class had been sent in to retrieve
the vial of the substance for external
study while a safe and direct route of
entry and exit had been planned for the
man to take he became critically ill
whilst in contact with 722 and developed
an aggressive fever no longer coherent
over the radio he dropped out of signal
wandering through the tunnels for 2
hours until emerging out of an exit high
up on the glacier two agents with higher
security clearance were dispatched to
deal with the body the reason for their
waight was for their own safety 722s
toxin appears to denature with time away
from its source causing it to weaken in
potency if they had approached
immediately they may have wells suffered
similar Fates to the d-class they
survived but the sample was ruined also
subsequent attempts have also been met
with failure it seems almost impossible
to capture a clean sample and transport
it any kind of distance with this toxin
the foundation would have possession of
an immense biological weapon akin to the
discovery of the atom bomb but as of
right now all it's good for is killing
d-class Personnel initially the
foundation believed the fluid to be a
defense mechanism for the SCP something
to protect it in its deep sleep but the
more time is spent observing it the more
more time this perception is Shifting
SCP 722s toxin appears instead to be a
weapon as such the containment of this
creature is of Paramount importance
there are eight known access points into
the tunnel Network that would Grant
access to SCP 722 each of them has been
sealed with reinforced gates with
additional layers of soundproofing at
regular 4-Hour intervals nitrogen gas
cooled to a near liquid state is to be
pumped through these doors without fail
It is believed that the creature is a
form of Proto reptile and so is
theoretically coldblooded its internal
temperature is dictated by its
surroundings therefore by keeping a cool
average temperature in these caves it is
thought that this SCP Slumber can be
prolonged how long is unclear with
Rising global temperatures year after
year the threat that the Greenpeace
activists were proclaiming is very real
just perhaps not quite in the way they'd
envisioned Not only would there be an
increase in natural disasters and a
decrease in biodiversity there would
also be a 12 km snake roaming around the
planet killing anyone in its path not
ideal as such the foundation has also
planted a number of Highly skilled
individuals in prominent environmental
positions in the hopes of turning the
tide of global warming sooner should the
ice in that cave system warm by even a
couple of degrees who knows what kind of
Spike they might see on the neural
monitors this SCP naturally is buried
deep beneath layers and layers of
security clearances too only in
exceptional circumstances and for Vital
maintenance is anyone allowed to
approach this SCP a minimum of two level
three clearance agents are required to
sign off on any such Works in recent
years a new Brigadier General took
charged of the containment operations of
SCP 722 after his predecessor was
stripped of his duties overly zealous
experiments and increasingly desperate
attempts to harvest or synthesize the
722 toxin saw an alarming uptick in
neural activity over 40 d-class
Personnel were processed and disposed of
within a 2E period in an attempt to
assemble a micro laboratory within the
main chamber itself this project failed
and the noises of construction
threatened the piece that had so long
been maintained beneath the glacier the
new Brigadier General is taking no such
risks enforcing a zero tolerance policy
on anyone approaching site 103 unless
suitably cleared a number of hikers have
sad had to be killed this way but the
foundation believes it to be a necessary
sacrifice to keep the peace it is quite
easy to find a convincing backstory for
their untimely deaths and the lack of
bodies to bury just another person to
get lost and fall down a crack in the
glacier warning stories that are shared
and planted in local towns and on the
internet the only threat to this current
piece is a new Avenue of inquiry that
researchers have stumbled across a link
to a group of animals found Halfway
Around the World monitor lizards of the
genus varanus seem to share a similar
set of traits to SCP 722 namely the
nature of their toxins you may be
familiar with the bite of a kodo dragon
while the initial wound sure does hurt
the real damage comes in the following
hours and days as necrosis sets in from
the toxins in its mouth could these
creatures share a common ancestor could
722 be the common ancestor as of right
now it is just a hunch but it's one that
has taken root amongst the research
staff in order to find out more though
they need samples tissue samples taken
straight from the SCP itself the only
way to do back is to go back into the
caves and start cutting if a bit of
construction noise was enough to raise
brain activity by .9% taking a hunk of
Flesh could prove a whole lot more
dangerous not least for the Personnel
involved who will all have to sacrifice
their lives the potential benefits could
be huge a way to study fatal disease es
in a new light perhaps finding a way to
reverse engineer cures to some of the
deadliest conditions on the planet or
perhaps the missing ingredient to
synthesizing the most powerful
biological weapon in human history maybe
worst of all it could all trigger The
Reawakening do you remember how the
story of yorong gundur ends with a
prediction that when the Great Serpent
un coils the end of the world Ragnarok
itself will arrive but that's just an
old fairy tale right
true horror the airplane door beling
smoke and a burning red light the dead
talking in ancient gutural Latin a
monstrous Angel made of rings wings and
eyes whipping Barbed tentacles at
screaming terrified priests you can
scarcely imagine a more hellish Place
Bishop Franklin's knees gave out under
him as soon as the man set foot back on
Solid Ground nearing his 70th th
birthday he'd never been a particularly
tough man but after the day he'd had he
doubted he'd ever be the same again
almost being ripped into another
dimension almost being at the center of
a nuclear explosion seeing he threw up
on the ground as the foundation
Personnel rushed over to him never never
again just 8 hours earlier Bishop
Franklin had been getting on with his
Friday preparations they had Mass coming
up this weekend so he was doing the
rounds of the cathedral putting out new
candles and straightening pews he was
nearly done ready to get on with the
rest of his morning when he saw two
suited figures entering the cathedral he
shuffled over to them trying to explain
that they were closed but quickly
faltered when he saw the grave look on
their faces just 10 minutes later he was
in the back of their car still holding a
spare candle with Agents from the SCP
Foundation sitting on either side of him
they handed him file after file each
most redacted explaining the basis of
who they were and where they were headed
it was a lot for the old priest to wrap
his head around he'd always believed in
a higher power and a spiritual realm but
this sounded a whole lot more serious
than that monsters aliens other
dimensions facilities portals he
questioned the agents on it they just
looked grimly from one to another as the
car wound its way to the private airst
strip in the middle of nowhere Bishop
Franklin had always hated flying but he
hated it a whole lot more as he
approached the airplane with no idea
where he'd be landing a small group of
men were gathered on the runway just by
the foot of a Boeing aircraft it seemed
like a pretty substantial plane for such
a small group of them he was at least a
little heartened to see that none of
them had brought luggage either in fact
most of them were just like him as
Bishop Franklin approached the group he
recognized various faces other Bishops
archbishops and Senior priests with him
there they totaled seven the others all
looked at him not saying much Bishop
Franklin tried his best to start asking
questions but two things happened in
quick succession that closed his mouth
very quickly firstly the luggage hold of
the plane was opened and two enormous
shapes were loaded into it via forklift
each shape had unmistakable symbols on
the sheets covering them nuclear danger
reeling from this Revelation Bishop
Franklin turned to the group to be face
to face with the Pope himself he
immediately shut his mouth you may also
be wondering what on Earth was going on
at this Airfield the truth is Bishop
Franklin along with six other Priests of
abrahamic faiths were about to embark on
the monthly flight of SCP
616 within this plane as all these men
were soon about to find out exists an
emergency door covered with satanic
iconography this door when opened at
ground level operates just like any
other emergency door leading to the
outside of the plane although any
individuals who had passed through this
door in this normal State reported
feeling heightened anxiety during and
after however once a month this door
will be anything but normal opening a
gate to well you'll soon see in order to
mitigate the threat posed to humanity
through
scp-616-1 or the gate the plane must be
in the Air at the time of its opening
far above and away from any human
settlements in order to keep this event
contained the door must be kept open for
the duration of the Portal's existence
until it has closed of its own accord
but holding this door open is not a
simple test of strength it is a test of
belief in order to protect all of
humanity from unknown horrors of a
cataclysmic scale seven Priests of
abrahamic faiths must be on board for
this monthly flight praying for the door
door to remain open the ability to keep
the door open it turns out is unrelated
to physical prowess but instead is based
entirely on one's own belief that the
door can be held open as such religious
figures praying to a higher power are
incredibly well suited to the task once
per year the flight is blessed by the
pope and every time the plane takes off
it must be holding two nuclear warheads
in its hall both can be remotely
detonated by the ground team who will in
constant radio communication with the
pilot should the pilot fail to give them
regular updates on the status of
scp-616-1 the event will be treated as
an XK class endof thee World scenario
and both nuclear devices will be
detonated without hesitation but Bishop
Franklin only knew about half of this
information from his redacted set of
documents and had forgotten half of them
on his stressful car Journey as he
strapped himself into a window seat he
was trembling like a leaf
he desperately wanted to complain about
being put into this situation but he
wasn't entirely sure who he would
complain to if he spoke to anyone
external about what he was about to
witness he had been told by the
foundation agents that he would be
administered with a Class C amnestic
whatever that meant he really didn't
want to find out fortunately for him the
most familiar of the faces from the
group of priests sat next to him in the
aisle seat Bishop what was his name
sensing Bishop Franklin's uncertainty
the man reached a hand over and warmly
reintroduced himself Bishop Pete they'd
met 2 years ago in Berlin just that
small action was almost enough to settle
Bishop Franklin's nerves as the plane
started to barrel down the runway almost
the plane took off causing the old man's
stomach to drop heart hammering he
looked around spotting the emergency
door it was just up ahead of him around
the middle of the fuselage it would have
looked like a normal emergency exit but
for the blood red markings scrawled
across it a wave of dread washed over
him it certainly looked evil that was
for sure trying his best to help Bishop
Pete struck up a conversation he
explained it wasn't his first time doing
this he'd been drafted to help 3 months
ago it was scary for sure but everything
was totally fine the foundation had
planned everything to a te it would have
helped Bishop Franklin's nerves but it
only made his mind jump to the nuclear
weapons he'd seen loaded into where his
suitcase would have normally gone the
two of them lapsed into silence for a
while no one on the plane was really
speaking he supposed he should have used
this opportunity to pray but according
to his briefing he'd be doing a lot of
that very soon he hadn't entirely
understood what the foundation had meant
by that he'd been told to pray to quote
keep the door open what had they meant
by that a bang shattered the silence as
the emergency door slammed wide open
open in an instant the plane went into a
nose dive as all the air rushed from
inside the lights went out for several
seconds then came back on in flashing
panicked spasms Bishop Franklin clung
for dear life onto the back of the chair
in front of him as the Roar of air
rushed around him it had gone dark
outside with shapeless clouds swirling
around him shaking the plane screaming
voices filled the aircraft not just the
voices of the men on board but women and
children too crying out in agony and
Terror through throats that sounded like
they'd been lashed with razor wire then
he saw it SCP
66-1 the gate was wide open smoke
billowed out of it crawling along the
floors of the cabin like an octopus
creeping its way along the ocean floor
red light seemed to spill out of it but
when he tried to look through the gate
itself it was like his brain wasn't
working anymore there were colors there
but there were ones he didn't recognize
I maybe they weren't colors at all it
was like his brain fixated on trying to
sort them into something that made sense
something rational a hand grasped his
arm and he turned to see Bishop Pete
staring at him with wild eyes the plane
was going down they could both feel it
and that emergency door was slowly
creeping shut they had been brought onto
this plane for one job only to pray like
their lives depended on it Bishop
Franklin screwed his eyes shut and
clasped his hands together he hadn't
prayed like that since he was a little
kid but he figured now was the time to
use all the tricks in the book he begged
and pleaded in a tiny voice for God to
keep that door open it felt so
counterintuitive so backwards to want to
keep that kind of door open as the air
roared in screamed around him but a
small voice inside of him told him to
persevere have a little faith but
suddenly the bishop noticed that the man
sitting alongside him had fallen silent
feeling like a naughty child at Mass he
opened one eye and peered sideways
Bishop Pete was still in his seat but
he' slumped over he wasn't breathing his
skin was cold to the touch deathly cold
then all of a sudden his head rocked
backwards and he started talking not
talking like a normal man but talking
like a man possessed his dead eyes
rolled around in his head aimlessly as
guttural voices rasped out of his throat
none of them were the words that Bishop
Franklin recognized they sounded almost
like Latin but far darker and more
ancient and the more the dead man spoke
the more the emergency door closed the
bishop started praying again much harder
this time digging his fingernails into
his palms so hard that he felt them
drawing blood he needed to keep this
door open he had to and he could he
believed it entirely in that moment the
door banged back open wider than ever
despite the chanting of the dead body in
the seat next to him nightmares swelled
to the Forefront of his mind as the
plane hurdled to the ground only the
plane wasn't hurdling to the ground in
fact it was flying at a perfectly steady
altitude of
10,972 M with an air speed of about 780
km an hour in fact aside from the death
of Bishop Pete everything within the
plane was going perfectly to plan deaths
of priests were just an occupational
hazard of keeping this SCP contained the
pilot at the front of the plane regarded
the whole situation playing out behind
him while feeding constant information
back to base everything was going
perfectly according to plan until the
angel appeared Bishop Franklin wasn't
the first one to see it that was the
unfortunate lot of Archbishop Michael
who was sitting closest to the emergency
door he first spited while staring
through into the void but his screams of
Terror warning those around him were
drowned out by all the other commotion
it was only when the angel's wings crept
their way through the edges of the door
and the creature LED itself into the
cabin that that the others saw it but by
this point it was too late for
Archbishop Michael the angel was not
like the angels we see in pop culture a
tall blonde person with white robes
fluffy wings and a gentle face it was a
shifting mass of eyes and tortured Wings
partially crawling along the ground
partially floating under the weight of
its massive frame it had to squeeze
itself through the door to fit into the
plane but as it did it lashed out at the
Archbishop with a seny tendril and got
to work violently killing him that was
when Bishop Franklin saw it and began to
panic he wanted nothing more than to
stop praying to let the emergency door
slam shut and keep this creature away
from them but that little voice inside
his head told him that wouldn't work if
that door was allowed to close before
the gate had then it would cause the
apocalypse he could not have that blood
on his hands so he prayed sweat pouring
down his face as the angel forced its
way through the gate and into the cabin
he prayed as it slumped across the
aisles working its way along the line of
men slaughtering them one by one he
prayed as it saw him and Rose to its
full height unfurling great wings and
readying itself for the kill and he
prayed as a wind more powerful than any
on Earth blew through the cabin and
pulled the angel back through the gate
the emergency door slammed shut and in
an instant the plane seemed to ride
itself no more turbulence no more wind
wind the light flickered once more and
then came back on steadily the seat belt
sign pinged off and oxygen masks dropped
from the ceiling about 4 hours too late
Bishop Franklin couldn't believe the
time when he looked at his wristwatch he
had been on this plane for weeks surely
not just 4 hours that was absurd it all
felt like a dream as the aircraft
circled around the air strip preparing
for landing everything in the plane
seemed totally normal to him now except
of course for the four dead bodies one
of which was slumped towards him in the
aisle seat the plane landed the bishop
staggered down the stairs and threw up
on the black top after a few awkward
moments the pilot sidled over to him and
muttered a quick thanks I was really
close to calling it a failure there and
having to set off them nukes I don't
know what you prayed for but you did
good today Bishop Franklin didn't feel
like he did good he felt like he'd had
his whole life his whole worldview
turned upside down in the space of an
inner state flight he had been moments
away from either being vaporized by a
nuclear bomb or from having economy
seats to the premiere of the destruction
of the World As We Knew It but just 31
days later Bishop Franklin was on that
same flight again praying his hardest as
the aircraft dropped into freef fall if
there was one thing that the foundation
noticed about working with religious
leaders it was that they had a real
determination to keep coming back to
help keep the world safe what the
foundation didn't have the heart to tell
them was that all of the satanic
markings on the door were actually fake
they had been added by researchers in an
attempt to make SCP
66-1 carry more significance for those
in the aircraft later testing revealed
that it was not exclusive to abrahamic
faiths or any faith groups for that
matter that they could keep the gate
open anyone who believed they could do
it was capable of it Faith leaders
however are still being utilized and the
blessing is still being performed formed
by the pope on a yearly basis it had
been found that these external rituals
while not necessarily directly impactful
have strengthened the belief and resolve
of those inside the plane yielding fewer
casualties and shorter durations various
experiments have been conducted to see
beyond the Event Horizon of the gate to
see what's on the other side those in
the plane have reported as having the
name Paradise despite never going inside
a remote controlled Rover was sent
inside the the gate on one experiment
but the footage was deemed far too
dangerous as all those who witnessed it
died within 2 months hopefully you
didn't peer too closely into the gate as
you watched this video the man's bedroom
hadn't been silent for over 100 years
now the carpet had been worn down a
thick layer of dust had gathered on
every surface and the same trapped air
had stagnated for so long that it become
unbearable for anyone entering the room
room but no one was allowed to enter the
room nobody could open that door ever
again or it could Mark the beginning of
not just an apocalypse but a breakdown
in the nature of reality itself figures
shuffled around the room sometimes
dozens sometimes as few as three all
rotting but never dying researchers
peered through the window in abject
Terror day after day as the laws of
physics broke down before their very
eyes all of them except one a lone
scientist with a plan to get inside that
room a plan that the foundation would
shoot him dead for a plan that he was
seconds away from enacting as the
improvised explosive device in his
Satchel clunked heavily against his
thigh in many ways we are just as
trapped as SCP 001 if not more so we are
trapped in our own three-dimensional
world take a stick figure drawn on a
piece of paper that stick figure know up
and down left and right and that is
their world you draw a box around them
and they are trapped unable to Simply
step forward out of the page and walk
around it for us looking down at the
stick figure we might laugh at their
foolishness trapped inside a child's
drawing of a house it begs the question
is there a creature looking down at us
and laughing we may be able to move up
and down left and ride forward and
backward outsmarting the simple stick
figure but in time we are just as caged
in living our entire lives on this razor
thin piece of paper called the present
the future is always just Out Of Reach
the past always repelling us we have no
choice but to exist in the now slowly
creeping through history without any
agency of our own curse to be born Live
and Die in that order you can never be a
child again never see your mother's face
for the first time beaming down at you
you cannot skip ahead to your dying
minutes knowing what it is you will have
to face up to in your life maybe the
idea of facing up to things at all will
fade with the freedom of exploring what
once was and what will be as if it were
no more difficult than taking a step out
of a 2d box the bell rang cutting
Professor Davies off he hadn't meant to
go into such an existential tangent
especially for his firste students most
of them looked like they were in a days
not really listening to anything he had
been saying quantum mechanics sure was a
complex topic to cover in just one
semester at University he'd spent his
entire career trying to wrap his head
around it and still spend most of his
days with the same bored and Confused
glaze over his eyes as the teenagers who
made their way to the back of the hall
but one figure standing just beyond the
doorway peering down at him caught the
professor's eye little did he know how
drastically his career was about to
change in just a few minutes a
preeminent physic IST at just 28 years
old Professor Davies had already
achieved the status that many academics
will not see within their lifetimes
whenever anyone asked him about it he
always made the joke that he was
cheating he didn't believe in the
concept of a linear lifetime in the
first place still too young to be taken
seriously by many of his peers he had
flown under the academic radar for much
of his career so far perhaps it was as
simple as that or perhaps certain
undercover agents had a hand in
suppressing news of his blossoming
career in Quantum research his hands
trembled as he approached the reinforced
glass he gripped the bag tightly trying
his best not to let his fear show if any
of them saw what he was about to do if
they even suspected something he would
have a dozen bullets flying through the
back of his skull before he'd even have
a chance to put his hands up shifting
his weight from foot to foot he waited
for the air lock to be open for him a
siren blared red lights flashed and the
first glass door slid open
stepping inside he waited for the
atmosphere in the chamber to adjust both
doors were closed in front of and behind
him if they wanted to kill him now would
be the time he closed his eyes and
waited with baited breath the bomb
weighing heavily on his shoulder but
they would not kill him he knew that now
what he was about to do was inevitable
it took several months for Professor
Davies to be granted the full security
clearance he needed they kept referring
to his project as a k class anomaly
whatever that meant in order to get him
up to speed with the nature of what he
was going to be working on the
foundation assigned him to various other
scps first SCP 5027 2821 1887 any
instance that had some link to Quantum
Mechanics or complex theoretical physics
they wouldn't even tell him which SCP he
was being trained up to work on until
one morning when a team of Agents was
waiting for him at the door to his
quarters he wasn't allowed to bring a
bag or any personal possessions standard
issue clothing a toothbrush and
everything else he needed would all be
provided for him it was only then that
they told him which SCP he was being
assigned to SCP 001 he was blindfolded
for the entirety of the journey car then
plane then another car it was a full 10
hours before his blindfold was removed
and his new project was revealed to him
professor Davies found himself in sight
01 the place where all of this started
all the scps all the research the
secrecy the assassinations the deaths of
countless innocent people and an equal
number of guilty parties it all started
right here site 01 the site itself
resembled a large sarcophagus similar to
the one found covering the Chernobyl
nuclear power plant where do you think
the Soviets got the blueprints from
everything in the room is arranged in a
circle around the center research desks
maintenance equipment raw Mater
materials including a stockpile of
wooden planks and reinforced Metal
Sheets monitoring equipment security
cameras and of course some of the most
advanced automatic weapon systems in the
world all pointed at a great glass box
in the middle of the hanger measuring 30
m in each Direction the glass was 50 cm
thick even all those High Caliber
weapons would have had a hard time
creating a chip in that but it wasn't
the glass box itself that was so
interesting it was what was trapped
inside of it a house inside a perfectly
round glass bowl with no entrances or
exits complete with a front lawn
sidewalk porch and even a tree in the
backyard a regular American house
trapped in a box like some kind of
science experiment there was some kind
of transparent airlock system at the
entrance on the other side was just a
normal walk up the garden path to the
edge of the second glass bubble
enclosing the house but on closer
inspection professor dve realized that
this wasn't your typical American house
at all the Street Lamp was an electric
it was made of iron with little glass
pained Windows an oil lamp in fact the
house did look odd to him there was no
electric doorbell but instead an actual
physical Bell System the whole house
looked out of place not just because it
was in a box in the central hanger of a
42,000 ton sarcophagus but because it
was from another era entirely you see
site 01 was constructed around this
house the glass box and bubble the
sarcophagus all of it was built around
the already existing building beneath
the foundations 100 m beneath the
surface is an immense metal plate that
forms a perfect seal with the defenses
up top the only way in and out of sight
01 is through an immense reinforced door
but even all those defenses will prove
utterly futile if anyone ever opens the
thin wooden door to the bedroom on the
top floor of the house that is the home
and the prison in which SCP 001 is
trapped it is the job of the foundation
to make sure that it remains trapped
there indefinitely what is SCP 001 as
Professor Davies made his way through
the airlock for the very first time and
entered the site under the supervision
of four of the highest ranking SCP staff
alive today he laid eyes on the entity
itself for the first time standing on a
scissor lift parked outside the front of
the house just inches away from the
glass bubble it was lifted high enough
to look through the window into what
looked like a young boy's bedroom on the
top floor layers of dust coated the
surfaces black and white photos sat in
frames antique children's toys sat all
around the walls but Davies didn't
notice any of them he was too busy
watching the men walking in all
directions unhurried but with purpose
well over a dozen men walked in all
directions across the carpeted floor
they were all identical around 6 ft with
heavy rotting skin that seemed to hang
off their limbs like it would a carcass
left in the sun human cadavers Milling
about in a young boy's bedroom Davies
was so taken back by their appearance
and behavior that it took him a long
time to notice something truly strange
the reason he was brought here in the
first place they were walking through
the bed in the middle of the room not
just over it or around it but straight
through it it as if it wasn't there but
wait something else was wrong too there
weren't 12 of them in the room it was
closer to 20 had he miscounted a moment
ago then he saw it take place one of the
cadavers reached the edge of the room
and paused as if in thought at that
moment it split not in half but rather
two versions of itself emerged from
where one had been standing both walking
in different directions a thrill of
excitement ran through Professor Davy's
body the uncertainty principle
it was there in action in front of him
he was looking at Schrodinger's cat
inside the box and seeing both its
corpse and its living self where
uncertainty exists this entity was
somehow embodying both possibilities in
real time he watched the two selves walk
around the room following different
paths for several minutes until
eventually they converged again back
into one being he turned to the
researcher accompanying him lit up with
excitement and asked what they were
doing here here the researcher's face
was Grim when he replied they're pacing
waiting the airlock door hissed open he
felt the stale 1800's air hitting his
face perfectly maintained at 20° in
front of him was the Garden Path leading
up to his goal that glass bubble ripping
the Satchel he set off up the path slow
enough not to attract any unwarranted
attention over the next few days
Professor Davies learned everything that
the foundation had on SCP 0 1 it had
been a human once a radical physicist
born in the late 19th century intent on
kickstarting the next Century with a
nuclear Renaissance the young man had
created a working model for stable
nuclear fusion the potential
ramifications were enormous free clean
electricity on a mass scale with no
harmful byproducts his research was
almost complete when a covert private
military group poisoned him with his own
radioactive nuclear agent the young man
made it back to his house house where he
died in his sleep that night powerful
military personnel and prominent
scientists who had been working
alongside the young man knew immediately
what had happened bursting into his home
they were about to walk through his
bedroom door and save him when they saw
the shadow of two feet standing by the
door then another pair the young
scientist had died but he also hadn't
much like Schrodinger's Cat the man was
suspended in a dual state of death and
not death this shocking Discovery led
the group of people present to form a
rudimentary Foundation established to
secure and contain their once friend
within his room never to be discovered
by The Wider world through close
observations since this time it has been
established that SCP 001 exists
independently of linear time in a kind
of superposition relative to the world
around it it is capable of occupying any
space that will or has been empty at any
point in time say you have two chairs in
a room one chair has always been there
the other was added to the room just 5
minutes before the SCP is unable to walk
through the chair that was always there
since it has always existed but the
chair that was added can be passed
through with no problem because there
was a point in time when that chair had
not been there but it also works in the
future if a third chair was present
which had always been there but was
removed 5 minutes after the experiment
SCP 001 could pass through that chair
also the foundation theorizes and hopes
that the start of this clock that has CP
001 operates on was the point at which
the young scientist died and did not die
that is why it is incapable of escaping
its bedroom and that is why it is of
vital importance that the bedroom door
remains closed forever ongoing
maintenance work and preservation
techniques are being employed to keep
the house in as stable of State as
possible should anything happen to
damage the Integrity of the structure
the quantum chaos contained in that
space could lead to a total breakdown of
the laws of physics destroying not just
the world but the fundamentals of
mathematics as we know them the bomb
bumped against Professor Davey's thigh
as he walked up to the house an old man
whose life had been devoted to denying
the world its future a reality where
what is and what could be are just as
real as one another a world where the
pain of living in the now Fades when you
can travel to any moment in your life
and relive its Joy when you aren't
trapped by the aging process infinite
Ren reble energy to solve The World's
problems a chance to see your deceased
loved ones again a way to look at the
universe Through The Eyes Of God the
head of 001 containment he had spent his
entire career overriding all of the
safeguards tweaking containment rules
just enough each year all so he could
walk across this grass with a satchel on
his shoulder and an explosive more
important than the atomic bomb at his
hip he approached the glass of the inner
sphere if he had done the math right
this should do just enough damage to
create a hole in the containment
structure the pressure change wouldn't
be too great inside but it should be
just enough to blow say a bedroom door
wide open the diver screams A Silent
Scream as the giant Squid's beak digs
into his skin it's many grasping
tentacles grabbing him and holding him
in place nearby his fellow divers are
driven half mad with Terror as they see
mysterious figures floating towards them
through the MC and strange Russian
voices speaking in their heads nobody
can help them they're down too deep too
consumed by the darkness and the
pressure of the sea they're now at the
mercy of whatever is inside the
submarine beginning in the 1940s with
the dawn of nuclear weapons the American
government conducting the world's first
atomic weapons test and the Soviet Union
responding in kind with nuclear testing
of their own the two Powers entered an
arms race fueled by rivalry and a thirst
to prove their strength on the world
stage What followed were Decades of
Staggering technological advancements as
each Nation tried to outdo and
intimidate the other the Soviet Union
crossed into the cold reaches of outer
space deploying the satellite Sputnik
the United States responded with the
founding of NASA tensions reached a
fever pitch during the Cuban Missile
Crisis of
1962 as United States citizens feared
they were teetering on the brink of
nuclear war in July of 1968 the Soviet
Union the United Kingdom and the United
States came together to sign the treaty
on the nonproliferation of nuclear
weapons agreeing to abandon their
pursuit of increasing nuclear power and
turn their focus to disarmament but
several months before the treaty was
signed the Soviet government was dealing
in Weaponry far more dangerous than
nuclear missiles something the other
world powers knew nothing about these
deadly sec secrets were hidden aboard a
submarine known as SCP 741 SCP 741 is
the underwater wreckage of a Soviet
submarine that sank in March of 1968 and
came into the custody of the SCP
Foundation in 1999 the submarine a
version of the Charlie 2 class was
deployed under unusual circumstances
which attracted the attention of the
United States government in an attempt
to learn more about the submarine the US
government launched project redacted
which attempted to recover the vessel
from the ocean in the early 1970s they
managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible uclid or
ker class anomaly in the rack at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hole was broken
into bits during Project R Ed recovery
attempt but was largely intact when it
first sank except for two holes one just
in front of the sail and one just below
the starboard missile tubes apparently
the vessel sank rapidly due to flooding
after an enemy missile strike which
occurred while it was surfacing though
all parts of the submarine are accounted
for no members of the crew have been
located additionally none of the
emergency escape equipment on board has
been used raising further questions
about what became of the crew wherever
they went they seem to have left
something behind whenever divers are
sent down to investigate the wreckage
they report experiencing anomalous
currents and strange sea life and
hearing moans disembodied voices and
incoherent Whispering they also report
seeing blurry faintly glowing figures
Additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a manned Expedition
into the water Waters around the
wreckage described in incident report
1741 daa divers a26 through a30 embarked
from the Icebreaker yamal into the
waters below with the intention of
studying the potential anomalous
activity surrounding the wreckage as the
group of divers approached the submarine
they could feel the shift in the water
around them the oppressive feeling of
abnormally increasing pressure bearing
down and threatening to crush them if
their specialized diving equipment were
to fail they knew that that would be it
and the command would have to come and
fish their corpses out of the water or
even worse they would vanish entirely
meeting the same mysterious fate as the
crew of that doomed submarine but they
couldn't fix it on that they had a job
to do at first glance the wreckage
appeared undisturbed unchanged since the
previous inspection still they needed to
take a closer look to be sure as the
team got closer to the vessel a30 was
startled by the sight of movement from
within the wreckage spot spotting motion
through one of the holes in the
structure as something passed by he
pointed it out to his colleagues but
they dismissed it as likely a giant
isopod or spider crab which were
crawling all over the surrounding area
a30 laughed off his jumpiness agreed
that they were probably right and
continued the exploration as planned
control authorized the divers to proceed
to the next step and a29 activated sonar
and lights moving toward the starboard
side breach there a faint glowing caught
his eye the glow resembled that of
radioactive material but when the team
checked the radiation levels in the area
they remained stable whatever the source
of the glow was it wasn't radioactive at
this point his Neutron counter began to
register something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
vili yini can you hear me the voice was
muffled and though it could be heard
over their communication channels it
emanated from somewhere in the wreckage
deep deep deep underwater as a29 watched
a glowing shape emerg from the darkness
it was only an outline the suggestion of
a silhouette but the shape was
undeniably familiar it looked like a
person the other divers quickly noted
the apparation 2 and began to panic some
checked their nitrogen levels believing
it to be some sort of nitrogen Narcosis
While others pointed out that they
couldn't all be suffering from nitrogen
Narcosis at the same time the unknown
voice continued speaking saying help me
it is getting hard to breathe the divers
debated what to do next questioning
whether what they were seeing was even
real when all at once the humanoid
figure vanished from sight the divers
attempted to shake off the startling
encounter and they resumed their duties
the investigation proceeding as normal
after a few moments of uneventful work
another Interruption presented itself in
the form of a 5 m long squid swimming
around the wreckage its presence
startled the divers at first
particularly those closest to the animal
but the others encouraged them to ignore
it citing the fact that there are no
records of these squid attacking humans
so they did continuing their work as the
squid circled them with apparent
curiosity a27 spotted an unusual shell
below the wreckage notably large and
difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat it
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible in order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a30 saw something else moving in the
depths he couldn't make out what it was
but the sight of it gave him a sick
feeling of dread deep in the pit of his
stomach the four divers were recovered
alive along with the shell examination
of the shell indicated that resembled
that of the extinct orthoconic
nautiloids but it was not fossilized it
was taken for further study given the
possible implication of extinct species
anomalously manifesting in the vicinity
of SCP 714 diver a26 lost a limb and was
exposed to an unknown Venom via bites
from the attacking squid his camera was
destroyed in the process as squid are
not known to attack humans unprovoked
this Behavior has been attributed to the
influence of SCP 741 though the exact
link between the two is yet to be
determined an anomalous pressure
gradient surrounds the wreck with a
radius of approximately 250 M starting
around the center of the submarine the
pressure in this area is much greater
than it should be given the depth of the
waterers there this unusually high
pressure makes sonar analysis extremely
difficult as well as threatening the
safety of any divers in the vicinity of
the rack the few records that the
foundation has managed to obtain from
the Russian and US governments indicate
that the submarine was being used to
transport some sort of secret cargo
though the specifics of this cargo are
still unknown there is reason to believe
that it differed from any type of
nuclear or chemical Weaponry on a date
redacted from official files the scps
Bist was patrolling the area around SCP
741 when it sonar detected some unknown
entity approaching SCP 741 from the
south at a pace of 46 knots the crew
compared the acoustic signature of the
contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
bisti attempted to reach the contact via
sonou drops and active sonar pings but
it did not respond when the contact
crossed into the total underwater
exclusion Zone it became classified as
hostile at that point the sonar recorded
sounds of an undersea missile launch and
basti responded with the utmost urgency
the ship broke away from its original
area and fired a type 53 torpedo at the
underwater threat 15 seconds seconds
after the bisti launched its torpedo
missiles of an unidentified
configuration were seen breaking the
water flying at a height of 1.8 m and a
velocity of 92 Mach the missiles did not
emit any detectable radar nor did they
respond to any launch chaff or flares
from the basti both of the missiles were
engaged by bti's 3K N5 kinsol surfac to
aair missiles and ctan point defense
systems and were destroyed at 18800 M
and 210 M from Impact respectively ly
after the missiles were neutralized the
Hostile vessel could be heard engaging
in evasive maneuvers at this point there
were four closely spaced explosions and
the sound of a submarine disintegrating
the identity of the attacker as well as
its intention toward SCP 741 have not
yet been determined the incident
resulted in the foundation research team
suggesting an expansion of the acoustic
sensor net as well as additional Patrol
and defense assets placed in the area
additionally they advised an acquisition
I of underc retaliatory capability the
incident was classified incident 1741 DC
the sonar recordings from the scps bisti
during incident 1741 DC were taken for
further analysis by the research team
the in-depth review revealed anomalous
acoustic signatures that did not match
up with any known forms of propulsion
including Magneto hydrodynamic Drive
currently the nature of the unidentified
attacker remains a mystery and it has
not been attributed to any particular
government or organization following the
incident involving the scps bisti an
American intelligence agent reached out
to the foundation offering further
insight into the secretive government
programs looking into SCP 741 he agreed
to sit for an interview with a
foundation researcher assigned to the
project on the condition that his
identity remained protected the SCP
researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
a foundation interview room and the
interviewer asked his informant why he
chose to come forward given the US
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years you've
seen those reports project redacted now
we know that part too how the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff that redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of and the crewmen
reburied Just Uniforms also the nuclear
device we recovered wasn't a missile or
torpedo Warhead it was a demolition
charge does that make any sense after
all those Clues I had to come forward
why the director and didn't is something
I can't fully explain this particular
statement puzzled the foundation
researcher raising questions he hadn't
anticipated only uniforms did this mean
that the sub had been unmanned the
informant replied no no not unmanned
there were no bodies but personal
effects were everywhere along with
uniforms there was some blood human
before you ask on one of the torpedoes
in a bit of skin where somebody probably
crushed his hand load in the thing just
no bodies left when I first looked into
all this I had no clue what the hell had
gone on down there but I started putting
things together the foundation agent
began to speculate based on the mounting
evidence could it have been a Soviet
weapons program a deadly biological
agent of some kind no no it wasn't that
I thought maybe it could have been so I
dialed up some of my contacts at bio
preparent as spies wind up owing each
other favors after a while and they
denied it vly not your usual cover up
Boney either they clearly stated that
whatever the sub was carrying it wasn't
theirs they want to know part of it
sound like he was going to puke when I
mentioned redacted doctor do you have
any idea what it takes to make a
bioweapons researchers sick now that
wasn't what really bugged me though what
really kept me awake at night was the
KGB file that fell into our hands they
mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the US of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too loan and you
half the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that SCP 741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships scps bisti and Kar has
been selected for this purpose if any
unauthorized activity occurs in the area
surrounding SCP 741 nuclear and
conventional missiles may be deployed
any movement of SCP 741 is grounds for
an immediate Nuclear Strike whatever
Secrets as CP 741 holds whatever it was
transporting that was even more of an
uncontrollable threat than nuclear
warfare they're better left alone down
there at the bottom of the sea those who
have studied the various anomalies
contained by the SCP Foundation know
that this world has quite a lot to fear
enormous World devouring monsters that
thrive on an endless stream of hate
seemingly innocuous statues waiting to
snap your neck the second you turn your
back and a shark eyed old man with the
power to reach through solid concrete
grab hold of you with his rotting hands
and drag you into his own personal hell
scp-106 can pop into our world whenever
he wants but like many of the most
efficient Predators he has his own
designated layer a pocket Dimension
where he can pull his prey and trap them
in a horrifying game of cat and mouse
that only ever ends one way in a painful
prolonged end we all know what scp-106
uses his pocket dimension for but what
if some of the other anomalies at the
foundation had a pocket dimension of
their very own a tiny parallel reality
that they could shape in their image and
use it for whatever they wanted what
might that look like a special team of
SCP Foundation operatives were tasked
with conducting an experiment using an
elaborate computer system to run
simulations and see what different
anomalies might do with their pocket
Dimensions should the opportunity ever
arise stranger things have certainly
happened at the SCP Foundation so they
prepared a list of anomalies that
presented the most potential for
interesting findings and fired up the
simulation for the very first subject
they selected an anomaly who was also a
colleague Dr bright and SCP
963 the monitor attached to the computer
running the simulation showed a curious
surprising picture there was a door with
one sign bright council meeting inside
past the door was a long conference
table packed to the brim with different
attendees the regards d-class scientists
men and women all wearing the trademark
anomalous amulet it was every single
incarnation of the doctor himself all
talking over each other with great
enthusiasm at the head of the table
there was a monitor depicting the
current incarnation of Dr brigh going
about his daily life on a live video
feed all of the many many Dr brights
were instructing him giving him advice
and guidance on every impulse and
decision some Dr brights were
brandishing pies others chainsaws and
others were drawing schematics for laser
guns and catapults the Council of
brights was working together devising
pranks schemes and general Tom Foolery
the research team all agreed that Dr
brigh could never learn about this
simulation result lest he tried to
recreate it himself next they inputed
details about SCP 1994 Miss J's whiz kid
Schoolhouse the anomalous computer
program capable of teaching anyone about
any subject with a triumphant beep the
computer announced that it had rendered
a simulation of what Miss Jay's pocket
Dimension might be it was a classroom
decorated in bright colors and cutouts
of various numbers and letters on the
wall motivational portraits were
displayed including kittens grabbing
onto the rungs of a ladder with the
slogan hang in there there were
bookshelves all along the walls filled
to the brim with books at the chalkboard
a three-dimensional version of Miss J
herself was standing with her signature
ponytail and bright green vest a piece
of chalk in her hand the desks were all
empty but she had a chipper smile on her
face and was waiting for students to
come in and learn at any minute on the
board she had written welcome class next
they chose an entity whose inner life
was a bit more difficult to discern
whose motivations though seemingly
straightforward were perplexing SCP 049
the plague doctor forever in pursuit of
curing a pestilence that he could not
get the foundation to understand
creating lifeless zombies whenever he
attempted to treat a patient where would
this inscrutable doctor disappear to if
he only could what would his Hideaway be
the simulation rendered a sterile
laboratory environment no real surprise
given his proclivity from Medical
Science there were stainless steel
tables and instruments the plague doctor
stood in the fully outfitted lab going
about his work as he always did with no
one to interrupt or disturb him on the
desk in the corner sat a pile of medical
texts a vase filled with lavender
flowers in fresh water and a generous
glass of Rich red wine there was
everything here that he could possibly
need what about a pocket dimension for
an entity that already had everything it
could possibly want something so content
so happy with its everyday life that it
had no need or desire to escape SCP 999
lived as a pampered pet a sort of
foundation mascot with its every wish
for tasty treats or playtime met still
they inputed the tickle monsters
information into the simulation to see
what it might come up with what it
rendered looked like something out of
wily Wonka and the Chocolate Factory it
was a wide open field beneath a bright
blue sky filled with sunlight and fluffy
white clouds the landscape however was
not the greenery and nature one might
expect sea but instead was made up
entirely of candy and other sweets
Boulders made of toffee a lake of melted
chocolate lollipop trees and cotton
candy bushes as far as the eye could see
nestled within the candy landscape was
an elaborate playground more of an
amusement park than the usual row of
swings and a plastic slide there was a
miniature Ferris wheel a ball pit and an
obstacle course that SCP 999 could
bounce around and navigate every simple
childlike Joy was present in this place
pure sweetness happiness and light for a
creature as good as SCP 999 they would
expect nothing less next up was the
deadly statue that moved only when out
of sight SCP
173 it took the researchers a moment to
understand what they were seeing when
they took a look at its Dimension at
first they thought that perhaps the
simulation had somehow crashed after all
they were looking at a pitch black
screen then they realized
they were seeing what its Dimension
would look like after all the perfect
place for SCP 173 to retreat to would be
somewhere cloaked in absolute Darkness
where no one could keep an eye on the
Statue and stop it from moving as it
pleased here it would be free to hunt
and take lives as much as it wanted
keeping unsuspecting humans in suspense
as they waited for the sound of grinding
stone to betray that the end was near
the researchers all shuddered and
glanced over their shoulders just in
case since they were already feeling
unsettled they decided to take it one
step further and see what SCP 682 might
create for itself what could be home for
the creature that hates everything they
were horrified to see a bleak Stony
landscape where the massive reptile was
devouring everything in sight humans
plants animals none were safe from being
snapped up in its deadly Jaws that
wasn't the worst of it though when it
had finished consuming in everything SCP
682 opened its mouth and coughed all of
its victims back up miraculously
resurrected and unharmed then it began
to do it all over again ripping tearing
and clawing at all the living things
around it in an endless cycle of Despair
one researcher began to feel sick and
had to flee the room the rest pressed on
if a bit paler than they had been
moments before since the Vibes in the
room were already as bad as they could
possibly get one researcher suggested
they keep the momentum going and try out
another highly hostile anomaly the
possessive mask itself SCP
035 what sort of cursed reality could
the simulation come up with for the
malicious mask a being that though it
could not move on its own seemed to
radiate an almost Unstoppable evil the
monitor showed a rendering of an
ornately decorated castle with a
medieval European Sensibility decor and
Rich red velvet curtains dots of black
and red like blood and black goo on
everything on the walls elaborate
tapestries were hung depicting the
traditional comedy and tragedy masks
that SCP 035 resembled there was a
stained glass window toward the back of
the room depicting SCP 035 with a full
human body sitting at top a Golden
Throne a crown on its head in the very
center of the room there was SCP p035 in
a position matching the stained glass
window at its feet dozens of people
dressed in rags were kneeling in
supplication to their ruler the mask was
smiling of course that awful thing would
want to make itself the king of its own
private Castle forcing others to serve
its every whim time to shift gears to
something completely different SCP
2662 also known as cthulu despite the
creature's intimidating appearance he
was over all a relatively polite being
what would his chosen Sanctuary look
like SCP 2662 simulated pocket Dimension
was a far cry from the luxury of SCP
035 there were no riches here no opulent
displays of wealth and power it was the
opposite the room depicted resembled a
standard studio apartment with a bed a
couch a television and a kitchenet every
up-to-date game console and some that
didn't exist yet could be seen
throughout the room and posters for
various video games and action and
Sci-Fi movies adorned the walls there
were Stacks and stacks of games ready to
be played as well as an extra- llarge
beam bag chair positioned directly in
front of the TV screen there SCP 2662
sat gaming happily the room had no
windows and no visible door either no
way for strangers to intrude on his
peaceful private Leisure Time up next on
the list was SCP 953 the polymorph
morphic humanoid but when the simulation
rendered her pocket Dimension she was
nowhere to be seen there was a beautiful
landscape like something out of a
painting of what appeared to be an
idyllic location in rural Korea there
was vibrant green grass a light blue sky
dotted with delicate wisps of clouds and
a clear trickling stream there was a man
Lying by the stream basking in the
sunlight though he didn't look like any
anomaly the research team recognized
they were checking him for The Telltale
fox ears or tail that indicated a
shape-shifted SCP 953 when suddenly a
figure emerged from the water a woman
with long dark hair wearing a white
dress and with those oh so familiar ears
poking out from her scalp she stretched
her sharp claws wide and snapped her
fingers suddenly the landscape changed
the sky went dark the clouds replaced
with Fox eyes glaring down from the
heavens the stream flowed red with blood
and the grass became a carpet of gnarled
orange fur the man scrambled to his feet
in a desperate bid for escape but SCP
953 jumped on him before he could so
much take a step away from her and began
to torture him gleefully the screen went
red as if with blood the researchers
definitely needed a pallet cleanser
after that nightmarish Vision so they
selected a much more wholesome entity
from the list for the next round SCP
2295 the patchwork bear that so deeply
wanted to heal the world and help the
sick and hurting its simulated Dimension
resembled an ordinary doctor's office
waiting room with chairs a check and
desk and some toys and books for board
patients of all ages there was one
difference however everything in the
room was made from scrap Fabric and yarn
materials the bear could use to patch a
potentially infinite number of troubles
this was a place where the bear could
bring anyone in need of its help and
treat them to the best of its ability
but what about an anomaly that was not
sentient or at the very least one whose
sentients was very much Up For Debate
the team selected SC SCP 914 for the
next simulation inputting the details of
914 or the Clockworks resulted in an
image of a small Factory with large
metal doors inside all manner of
unidentifiable Machinery worked in
tandem to rearrange and reconfigure
various items there were different
conveyor belts each marked according to
one of the Clockwork settings
coarse rough one: one fine and very fine
perhaps one researcher posited this
pocket Dimension was not theoretical at
all maybe this was where items went when
they disappeared into the machine's
intake Booth then again who could be
certain how exactly an item like SCP 914
really worked next was SCP 073 or Kane
in his Dimension the world of his own
making he strolled through a dense
forest the vegetation thriving all
around found him where it would have
ordinarily withered and died he plucked
an apple off a tree and took a bite SCP
529 Josie the half cat run through a
playroom that could only be described as
cat Heaven scratching posts Fish and
Chicken Treats balls of yarn everything
a feline friend could ever desire one
researcher wiped a tear from her eye and
when her colleagues questioned it she
just replied I really like cats okay in
a subject change another researcher
suggested trying a sort of of before and
after experiment with the simulation
they would see what sort of pocket
Dimension might be generated by an
anomaly before a traumatic event and
what it might create after they settled
on SCP 066 Eric's toy first they built
the simulation around SCP 066 as it
first behaved when it arrived at the SCP
Foundation the result produced was a
world made of colorful yarn filled with
living yarn creatures roaming around the
landscape as Eric's toy rolled among
them cheerfully then they inputed the
details of the incident that shifted the
entity's behavior when a d-class
attempted to cut off a piece of its yarn
body for study the resulting pocket
Dimension was made not of yarn but of
fleshy tendrils dripping with red that
curled and wried like tentacles grasping
and squeezing aggressively at anything
that intruded on the space a striking
visual representation of the change in
the anomaly's mental and emotional state
now next was SCP
1867 Lord Blackwood Lord blackwood's
pocket out of reality was the interior
of a grand hunting lodge with a roaring
fire in the fireplace and an impressive
if a bit macabra bare skin rug stretched
across the floor Lord Blackwood stood in
all of his brightly colored sea slug
Glory at a bar in the corner of the room
next to a glass of whiskey and a
handcarved wooden pipe All Along The
Wall were various trophies Taxidermy of
a Vari iety of wild beasts that the slug
had hunted over the years as well as
artifacts picked up along its travels
fossils rare books paintings and
primitive weapons there were also grainy
old photographs of Lord Blackwood with
many of his associates from over the
years other famed hunters and gentlemen
explorers he had embarked on his
Expeditions alongside SCP 4910 the grer
would dwell in a volcanic landscape
where Rock and lava were replaced with
fleshy pink gums and te teeth jutted out
of every available surface gnarly SCP
076 able would use his pocket Dimension
as a battle arena a grand Coliseum of
sorts filled with every weapon
imaginable where he could trap his
strongest wouldbe opponents and force
them into a fight to the death SCP 527
Mr fish's simulated Pocket World
resembled the city of Boston with one
notable difference every depiction of a
human being from statues to billboard
advertis ments to magazine covers showed
them with fish heads at top their human
bodies there was not a human head to be
seen except at what would have
ordinarily been the seafood market there
you could find chests of ice held fresh
human heads that were ready to be sold
though the sight of the human heads was
a bit disconcerting the research team
understood the significance of this
place it made sense that Mr Fish would
want to retreat to a world that matched
his lived experience where everyone else
looked looked like him there was even a
hat shop stocked with tiny little formal
hats like his very own top hat if SCP
2800 cactus man had a place between
realities that belonged exclusively to
him it would be an underground superhero
Hideout the room depicted on the monitor
resembled the Batcave but with all of
the bat themed Decor replaced with
cactus themed items instead there were
also several large sagoro cacti planted
in pots throughout the space as well as
several cactus man costumes in glass
cases ready to be worn SCP 294 the
coffee machine would have a secret world
filled with every liquid substance known
to man and several still undiscovered
floating through the air but somehow
never mixing together any beverage
anyone could ever ask for would be there
just waiting for the right order to come
in SCP 352 Baba Yaga was next it was a
large Forest seemingly ordinary at first
glance but within its depths lurked
every fear a person could ever have
depending on what unsuspecting victim
she was able to pull into the darkness
there could be a high up Cliffside
waiting for someone afraid of heights a
giant spider awaiting an arachnophobe or
thick Inky Blackness waiting for someone
Afraid of the Dark all around the forest
floor her hair curled waiting to ens
snare her prey SCP 662 more specifically
SCP
6621 Mr Deeds quite possibly already
occupied a pocket Dimension when his
Bell was not in use though they had no
way to know for certain the simulation
predicted that his break room of sorts
might look like this a blue room with
two shelves filled with cleaning tools a
brown couch and a little bed in the
corner where the Butler could sleep
during his time off SCP 169 Leviathan
would disappear into an aquatic pocket
Dimension a place large enough for it to
swim comfortably possibly forever in the
peaceful infinite ocean then the
research staff decided to input scp096
and see what the shyu pocket Dimension
might look like unlike the old man this
anomaly was not aggressive all the time
and it seemed to take no pleasure in
hunting instead it acted in a kind of
Twisted self-defense attacking anything
that saw its face and set it off on a
spree of violence that ended in death
scp096 his potential pocket Dimension
was a dark dis small Labyrinth like
something out of the Greek myth of the
minitar stone corridors Twisted this way
and that leading any potential Intruders
down dead ends and away from the center
where scp096 hid from sight in the
center there was light and Life trees
grass a small pond and a nest filled
with blind birds chirping and singing to
scp096 as it sat in complete obscurity
away from prying eyes it was July 2007
and the dry New Mexico heat could
shrivel your average Outsider into the
size of a small keychain Melinda and
Bailey two young women dressed in
impeccable costumes of the Harry Potter
characters Luna loveg good and Hermione
Granger were getting ready for a
momentous event the release of Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows the final
installment in the Epic Saga of the boy
Wizard and his quest to defeat the evil
Lord vold
they like so many other cosplaying fans
had driven out to page one books an
Exquisite bookstore in the very heart of
Albuquerque it was miles from where the
two of them had lived but more than
worth the drive to be part of the
potterhead fever long before the series
author would lose her mind on Twitter
and make the books a lot harder for most
people to enjoy trans writes by the way
Bailey and Melinda were counting the
seconds until the bookstore's doors
finally opened and they could get the
answers to so many of their burning
questions why had Snape killed
Dumbledore would Harry Ron and Hermione
find and destroyed the last few
horcruxes allowing them to finally
destroy Lord Voldemort once and for all
and most importantly of all would their
ships sail Mel was Harry Hermione all
the way but Bailey controversially was
all about Ron and Draco the two of them
couldn't be more excited to be part of
literary history like this the
bookstore's doors opened and little by
little the line fed in it was worth the
long drive in the late evening and
facing the sweltering summer heat when
the two of them were holding copies of
Harry Potter in the Deathly Hollows and
walking back to their car they knew it
had all been worth it Mel thought this
must have been how Jesus felt when he
finished writing the first edition of
the Old Testament history incidentally
had never been Mel's strong suit Melinda
and Bailey set off back to their homes
in the sticks Bailey was driving she'd
been kind enough to give Mel a lift
knowing they were probably their
neighborhood's biggest potterheads it
warmed their hearts to see all this
enthusiasm for the book series they
loved so fondly seeing so many others in
costume or with vinyl decals or bumper
stickers in their cars declaring their
love of the franchise they'd seen Hagrid
grabbing a mocha in Starbucks madiy
Moody had been filling up his Buick at
the gas Eng Gulp and Cirrus black had
passed out from heatstroke and needed to
be attended to medically with an all
black costume in this kind of weather
that much was basically inevitable as
Bailey and Melinda continued their Drive
drawing closer to the witchy Wilderness
of sibola national forest they continued
sharing their thoughts feelings and
predictions about the book to come they
couldn't wait to read it was it even
possible for someone to be this amped
about a book their enthusiasm was so
great they didn't even notice on those
long winding back roads that another car
had started following them it was 8:15
p.m. now pitch black the kind of dark
where bad things happen evidently during
a lull in the conversation Mel turned
her eyes up to the rear view mirror and
spotted the car behind them it was a car
they'd recognize anywhere a turquoise
blue Ford Anglia 105e to some this would
be a mostly unrecognizable if a little
old-fashioned car but to Melinda and
Bailey It could only ever be the
enchanted vehicle of Arthur Weasley the
father of series Mainstay Ron Weasley
the car which had become iconic since
being featured in the books and films
was able to fly and turn invisible and
had gotten the main characters both into
and out of a variety of amusing scrapes
Mel told Bailey to take a look and she
couldn't help but chuckle in admiration
plenty of Harry Potter fans were in town
tonight and some took it further than
others at times Bailey wondered if her
three Harry Potter bumper stickers
reading my other ride is a nimbus 2000
save gas take the night bus and all
aboard the Hogwarts Express respectively
were a little excessive and then there
was whoever this was whose intense Harry
Potter fandom LED them to buy an
authentic Harry Potter car neither
Bailey nor Mel could make out the driver
the car's windshield was slightly fogged
up strange strange seeing as it was such
a hot evening out they noticed that the
car also must have had broken turn
signals because anytime the car needed
to make a turn the driver's arm would
slide out the window and make the
appropriate gesture the Ford Anglia kept
pace with him following them at every
single turn it was only then that they
noticed something a little odd the car
didn't have a license plate it was
almost as though all identifying
features for the car or its driver had
been obscured Bailey who was getting a
little nervous at this point decided to
try out a little experiment at the next
three intersections she took three left
turns it seemed improbable that anyone
would actually intend to take a route
that would lead them in a circle and yet
the Ford Anglia did just that Bailey's
most frightening suspicion was confirmed
they were being followed she didn't need
to tell Melinda seeing as the bad vibes
radiating off the car were already
palpable the two assessed their options
they couldn't drive home after all the
last thing you'd want is a crazy person
knowing where you live their best bet
was to drive to a heavily populated area
say the center of Albuquerque during one
of the most highly anticipated book
launches in recent memory or better yet
the local police station whoever was
driving this car wouldn't dare try
anything there Bailey and Melinda sped
up and took off in the direction of the
city but to their horror the fort Anglia
sped up in kind Bailey was pressing the
gas pedal down to the floorboards and
still the fort Anglia gained its
headlights glowing like menacing white
eyes in an instant it pulled ahead of
them the driver's hand emerging once
again this time it signaled for them to
stop the two of them would sooner Drive
their car off a cliff than stopped for
whoever was behind the murky front
window of the fort Anglia as the Ford
began to slow perhaps hoping to box them
in Bailey pounded on the gas again and
lurched forward weaving around the Ford
and passing it once more their two
copies of Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows were rattling around in the back
seats neither Bailey nor Melinda
expected this night to end in a car
chase but it wouldn't be the last time
their expectations would be dashed
Before Sunrise the two potterheads were
in the lead again but it would still be
7 or 8 miles before they were officially
out of sabola national forest Bailey
drove as fast as she could she and
Melinda were frantic messes of Terror
and adrenaline now but the Ford Anglia
kept moving gaining on them with every
second that passed go faster godamn it
faster Melinda screamed in horror I'm
going as fast as I can Bailey yeled back
the car merged into the lane next to
them and sped forward again they were
neck and neck now but it was still too
dark inside the other car to make out
the driver just as Mel was wishing that
she could have a closer look her wish
was granted in the worst way possible
the Fort Anglia abruptly moved to the
side and slammed against them knocking
them off course with a sudden shocking
blow the shock knocked Bailey sideways
in the car and yanked the steering wheel
along with them the car veered off the
side of the road and tumbled down the
grassy embankment towards the trees
taking the two unfortunate potterheads
down with it before they knew it their
Fender was wrapped around the trunk of a
ponderosa pine tree if it wasn't for
their seat belts and airbags they would
have died instantly but perhaps in the
end that would have been Mercy Melinda
and Bailey sat up as the airbags
deflated in front of them the car was
total as the two of them shakely
unbuckled their seat belts and climbed
out of the car they were bathed in the
light of the Ford anglia's headlights
from above as though they were about to
be abducted by a UFO's tractor beam the
Ford was just waiting on the road above
them its engine rumbled like a low
beastial growl the driver was still
obscured behind the foggy windshield but
their arm was hanging out of the window
once more Bailey and Melinda were too
frightened and dazed by the crash to
even move as the car began advancing
with unnatural Grace down the embankment
before them it clambered towards them
with such uncanny intent that it seemed
almost like it had a mind of its own
rather than a machine being piloted by a
human being Melinda pointed forwards and
screamed she saw something Bailey didn't
there was something on the outstretched
palm of the driver's hand she thought it
was a tattoo at first until she saw it
move two human eyes were fixed into the
center of the flesh staring directly at
her like a crustacean's eyes on stalks
moments later the car was upon them and
Melinda's scream was silenced a
concerned passer by found Bailey's
abandoned car crashed in the ditch
beside the road the next morning the two
women were never found and two bashed up
copies of Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows were discovered on the car's
floor among all the shards of broken
glass never to be read some days can be
magical just not in the ways you would
have hoped especially if you run a foul
of SCP 3470 a uclid class anomaly
somewhat cruy nicknamed Harry Potter's
Revenge sadly kidnappings and car
accidents aren't that uncommon in this
strange scary world we live in but at a
certain point the SCP foundation's many
field agents detected a strange pattern
in a series of car accidents near sabola
National Forest in New Mexico in all
these instances the cars had been found
crashed but there were never any bodies
eagle-eyed police police officers
studying the crash also picked up
another more subtle detail in all these
events the cars had turquoise blue paint
chips on them even if the cars
themselves weren't blue suggesting the
impact of another car Foundation
Eggheads correlated this with another
strange report they' received out of New
Mexico a young couple had narrowly
avoided a dangerous incident when a car
matching the description of a classic
Ford Anglia 105e tried to flag them down
on a dark and Lonely Road near sabola
National Forest just like Bailey and
Melinda the duo were unable to see the
driver behind the fogged up windshield
however when they got close enough to
see the driver's hand they both attested
that it had eyes on its Palm describing
it as similar to the terrifying Pale Man
from the movie Pan's Labyrinth with all
of these frightening and clearly
anomalous data points in place the SCP
Foundation decided it was time to do
their due diligence and go on the hunt
for this predatory car it wouldn't be
the first time they tackled a istic or
carnivorous vehicle and because of this
experience they weren't going in
unprepared there was of course A CP 2086
also known as the man eating bus these
were a species of huge insect-like
creatures who'd evolv to perfectly mimic
your average city bus in order to lure
prey into their bodies another notable
instance was SC SCP 1386 also known as
The Living ice cream van this being is
even more mysterious than the man eating
buses and boasts a wide range of
abilities from a hazardous form to a
fleshy appendage somewhat similar to the
arm emerging from SCP 3470 the jury
still out on whether either of these
anomalies are in any way directly
connected to SCP 3470 but it gave thep
Foundation a few ideas on how exactly to
engage study and potentially even
contain this new vehicular slaughterer
of man as you've probably come to expect
by this point where there are still so
many unknown VAR involved the foundation
decided to fall back on Old Faithful
throwing a couple of DCL classes at it
and just seeing what happened two were
selected placed in a standard foundation
off-road vehicle with Dash and rear cams
and given a variety of equipment
including a special semi-automatic
assault rifle with armor-piercing rounds
each one containing a micro GPS that
would allow the foundation to continue
tracking SCP 3470 after initial contact
and if in the process of the experiment
SCP 3470 revealed some frightening new
powers then a standard vehicle and a
pair of DCL classes weren't much of a
loss once again another hapless Duo were
sent off on the roads in the proximity
of sabola national park though the
foundation hoped these two would at
least end the night accounted for they
patrolled the roads once or twice
remarking on the beauty on the stars
above while not much of anything
happened command kept close tabs on them
back at the nearest containment site
feeding orders through earpieces and
watching the live video F S as the drive
continued the two DCL classes finally
encountered SCP 3470 they get closer at
which point s SCP 3470 begins its
typical pattern of hunting Behavior it
merged onto the road next to the d-class
vehicle and began to slide alongside
them that's when the two DCL classes
realized and couldn't help but remark
that this looked just like the car from
Harry Potter was Hogwart School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry a new group of
interests now had Lord Voldemort entered
into an allegiance with the Scarlet King
this was hilarious of course it didn't
remain all that funny to the DCL classes
for long the anomalous Ford Anglia
suddenly pulled up in front of them and
ground to an abrupt halt forcing the
declass driving to pound the brakes
startling both of them that's when the
human arm slithered out from the
anglia's open window and made the stop
signal before twisting around and
revealing the two staring human eyes
embedded in its Palm the DCL classes
started to panic and reverse away while
the car started chasing them at
terrifying speeds Foundation command
kept ordering the d-class riding shotgun
to live up to his title and blast the
vehicle with one of the tracking bullets
but the driver was so terrified he
refused to slow down and give his fellow
d-class a clear shot as a result the
armed d-class released a flurry of shots
and just got lucky that some of them
happened to strike the car this caused
it to let out a terrible pain shriek
comparable to the squeal of breaking car
tires SCP 3470 then retreated allowing
the DCL classes to safely return to BAS
Bas while command tracked the Ford
Anglia back to its native habitat it was
time for the next phase of the mission
to begin the foundation brought in
Mobile task force Lambda 12 also known
as The Pest controllers a group of
operatives who specialize in taking down
particularly verminous creatures they'd
be the ones to track down SCP 3470s nest
and find out what they were really up
against here in order to complete the
mission four members of the task force
were designated for infiltration while
two others were designated to keep watch
outside the infiltrators were given
reinforced armor and a wide selection of
weapons and tools including a
flamethrower a tranquilizer gun a net
gun and a light machine gun SCP 3470s
movements were tracked back to a cave in
sabola National Forest when the
infiltration team entered they saw track
marks with a familiar tire tread on the
floor and walls of the cave which
suggested a number of frightening things
about the anomaly they were chasing as
they got deeper into the cave the air
became intensely hot and humid they
found scat piles filled with human bones
and a local sheriff's badge suggesting
that the car does indeed eat and digest
its prey but most terrifying of all the
infiltration team discovered a number of
translucent eggs which had small
quadrupedal organisms assumed to be the
larval stage of SCP 3470 wriggling away
inside they collected some of the eggs
and then burned the rest before turning
around to leave that's when they noticed
that SCP 3470 was in the cave mouth
waiting for them except this one wasn't
turquoise like the other this one was
black the car began revving aggressively
after a 10th standoff in which one of
the task force members muttered I refuse
to be killed by a godamn Ford the Task
Force member with the light machine gun
opened fire on the car's exposed arm one
of the bullets hit the creature in one
of its hand eyes causing it to let out
another pain shriek and Retreat from the
cave mouth allowing the task force to
finally escape the two who were meant to
be on the lookout were never seen again
SCP 3470 remains at large with the pest
controllers doing whatever they can to
track it down and contain it the eggs
are also subject to further study in the
meantime be careful who you stop for
because if you end up inside this
magical Ford Anglia an encounter with
the wng willow is going to be the least
of your worries roll up roll up Step
Right This Way ladies and gentlemen on
the other side of these canvas doors
you're about to witness something so
monstrous so hideous so repulsive that
it will turn your stomachs and fill you
with amazement the creature you'll find
in this tent has been known to elicit
all manner of responses from well-to-do
folks like yourselves you may want to
laugh at it you may want to strike it
down you may even want to throw rotten
fruit at it and believe you me we are
prepared for that you will find all
manner of Rotten Tomatoes eggs and other
festering foods that are begging to be
pelted for the low low price of 5 cents
per handful if you follow me through
these doors and gather around this cage
quietly perhaps you will see it wait for
your eyes to adjust to the dark and hold
your revulsion until you cannot bear it
anymore only then will we get to look at
the papery gray skin sagging loose over
a swollen gut Marvel at its three trunk
legs barely strong enough to support its
own weight its deformed trunk that hangs
limp off the front of its face and its
ridiculous ears that flap nervously when
it it's afraid don't be afraid of the
Tusk sticking out from its face or its
cries of pain and anguish instead hold
your tongues and wait for if you're
patient enough and perhaps with a slight
beating it may even play us a song with
the valves on its trunk then and only
then you're permitted to pel the
Elephant Man with whatever you see fit
as you bask in the glory of Herman
Fuller's circus of the disquieting Reese
Freeman didn't have much of a choice but
to join the circus at the age of 14 the
cast out son of a freed slave in New
Orleans he spent much of his early life
wandering the streets trying not to get
into any trouble in the late 1800s very
few places were interested in hiring a
young black man unless of course they
were looking to turn him back to the
life that his father had fought so hard
to escape that's why when Reese was out
fishing one afternoon and saw a big red
tent going up on the outskirts of town
he couldn't help but Wander Over much to
his surprise a group of black men were
the ones raising the Marquee they didn't
look like slaves either Reese had never
heard of a circus the closest he'd ever
come to seeing was a traveling
entertainment cart that would sometimes
pop up around town with a dancing bear
in a cage or glass ball and a pack of
tarot cards the brightly colored tents
that went up one after another were
enough to draw a crowd even the most
well-respected in New Orleans came out
for a look standing ankled deep in the
river Reese peered over at the man who
came out to address the throng dressed
in a long tail coat with a tall Top Hat
the man stood on a box of fruit and
waved a cane dramatically in the air
good folks of New Orleans what you're
about to witness tonight has never
before been seen this side of the
Mississippi wonders and amazement Galore
spectacle and intrig mystery in Mayhem
and just a touch of the impossible I go
by the name of Herman Fuller the most
talented and notorious circus master in
the entire United States the dazzling
array of shows that I've brought before
you is not for the faint of heart or the
weak of constitution your stomachs will
be turned and your minds may be altered
but it promises to be a knight that you
will never forget Reese wasn't much
interested in any of what he had just
said this kind of Two Penny show was
reserved for the folks who had the money
to throw around on needless things like
smiling and having a nice evening W
Reese was far more interested in were
the groups of men working behind the
scenes pulling various carts and setting
up all of the Stalls a lot of them
didn't look much older than him a grin
spread across his face SCP 4409 insisted
on being interviewed in the dark with
all the lights in the interview chamber
Switched Off Dr Simon Crossley entered
the room and sat down across from the
Elephant Man even in the dim light
though he was able to still make out
part of the man's features the ivory
tongue s the hanging nose and the
nervously twitching ears the man had
been picked up in St Louis where local
police had found him panhandling in the
streets while he certainly seemed
harmless enough it was important for the
foundation to take him in just to be
sure sitting in the dark interview room
ree Freeman was apprehensive at first
about telling his side of the story a
life of being mocked spat on and chased
out of towns had left him with a real
distrust of other people that was
probably made worse by his apprehension
at being put in another cage within the
foundation he told Dr Crossley that he
was born as normal as could be that his
current ghastly Affliction was something
done to him quite some time ago but as
much as it pained him to recollect it
was a tale that he knew he'd probably
have to tell Dr Crossley replied that he
was all ears it took Dr Crossley a few
seconds to realize his faux paw SCP 4409
glared at him before continuing to
explain how he was made the way he was
Rees Freeman had managed to land a job
with the circus surprisingly easily
despite having no previous experience
and no references to back him up Herman
Fuller took a shine to him it was menial
work and not many folks were up to doing
it but since reys had never had a job
before he didn't know any better he
started out at the bottom of the ladder
scraping out feces washing down old
cages and carrying heavy crates the one
scrawny 14-year-old boy quickly turned
into a stocky 17-year-old with broad
shoulders and strong legs they would
travel from town to town across most of
the United States stopping off in major
cities for weeks at a time to bring in
as much money as possible before moving
on Reese didn't save much of that money
but he didn't mind the fact that he got
two meals a day and something to do with
himself was enough in fact he kind of
enjoyed sleeping on top of the carts as
the horses pulled them across the dusty
American roads the one thing that always
seemed to affect him though was that he
was never allowed to actually see inside
the tents he would see folks come and go
through the canvas doors week after week
but was never allowed so much as a peak
inside himself the older guys were
responsible for throwing the canvas
sheets over the cages which would remain
that way as they traveled not having
seen much of the world at that point
Reese didn't have much of an idea of
what could be in those cages perhaps
some kind of animal from a foreign
country something from Africa or Asia
they made all kind kinds of noise Reese
said that most of them sounded like
humans but then they'd go and make
strange animal sounds that no human
mouth could ever produce one night his
curiosity got the better of him hanging
back before the crowds got into the tent
he Sid stepped over to the entrance
making sure that no one saw him and took
a peek through the doorway it was dark
inside too dark to make out much of what
was happening the crowd of people was
standing between him and the cage all
jostling and leaning this way in that
trying to make out whatever it was that
was inside a screeching sound filled the
air making the whole crowd and Reese
outside jump right standing on his
tiptoes he tried his best to see what
was moving around in that cage it seemed
to be moving around like a person
lurching this way and that but the
sounds coming from it sounded more like
a bird and sure enough after a moment a
huge pair of disproportionately ugly
Wings stretched out from either side of
the creature flapping and sending a rush
of air through the tent so powerful that
it blew the flap wide open in front of
him just as Herman Fuller turned around
to see him standing there ree bolted and
hid behind one of the carts he was going
to be in trouble for this he was sure of
it it was one of Fuller's only rules of
the circus and he had just gone and
broken it he was in the hottest water
imaginable but as nighttime fell and the
drags of the spectators wandered out of
the tent Fuller seemed to be in two bad
a mood at all watching him from a
distance ree got the impression that he
might not actually be in as much trouble
as he thought Fuller caught his eye and
came over Kane twirling and Top Hat
sitting jauntily at top his head Reese
got off on the wrong foot apologizing
right away for spying into the tent the
circus Master just laughed it off and
slapped him on the back Reese my boy
don't worry about it I've got much
bigger plans for you much much bigger
that night as Reese lay in bed he had a
terrible dream about what he had seen in
the tent that day circus of the
disquieting was certainly an apt title
for this place the image of that strange
shadowy bird person in the cage haunted
his nightmares until suddenly two pairs
of strong hands gripped him and ripped
him out of his sleep he knew better than
to fight back this was surely going to
be his comeuppence for breaking Fuller's
rules earlier they dragged him into the
main tent where there was an oil lamp in
the middle Illuminating what looked like
a heavy wooden operating table his
wrists and ankles were strapped in and
then the two men left him alone he had
half a mind to scream but with all the
Caged up creatures from the circus
around him he doubted anyone would pay
him much mind it was almost an hour
before Herman Fuller walked into the
tent by this point reys expected him to
be walking in with surgical equipment
gloves maybe even a saw but the man had
nothing in his bare hands Herman Fuller
asked him if he ever heard of Joseph
Merck Reese didn't answer of course he
had heard of the Elephant Man the whole
world had been talking about Joseph
Merrick for months a man born so
hideously deformed that people had
compared him to an elephant though the
resemblance wasn't that convincing this
sentiment was clearly shared by Fuller
who placed one hand on either side of
rees's face and began to softly massage
his cheeks explaining how disappointed
he was that merik didn't actually look
all that much like an elephant Reese's
cheeks started to hurt as the man
massaged him almost as if he was
stretching and pulling at his face
finding loose skin the boy asked Fuller
what he was doing the circus Master just
smiled at him and explained that it was
an old technique handed down in his
family a gift he called it he started
touching Reese's nose gently pulling at
it with more and more pressure much to
Reese's surprise he felt his nose
elongating growing longer and longer in
the man's hand he tried to Twitch his
face and was was starting to find that
his new nose twitched along with it the
longer it grew the more painful it felt
the skin and flesh from his head being
ripped and pulled into a new shape at
several points Reese felt ready to pass
out from the agony but the circus Master
kept talking to him kept him awake
through the whole ordeal as he molded
the boy's face like clay into the shape
of an elephant lying on the bench
panting reys could see his trunk from
between his two eyes it was a nightmare
that was all was but then Fuller reached
under the workbench and lifted out a
small hand drill one by one he punched
holes into the top of Reese's trunk
installing little valves like a trumpet
as he went standing back to admire his
handiwork he told Reese that he would be
his new favorite attraction my boy I
have made you into a star the tusks did
not come straight away over the course
of several months they slowly and
painfully Yul emerged from his deformed
jaw his elephantine legs were also not
part of his initial transformation but
instead came as a result of health
issues he developed while being trapped
in a cage for several decades crowds of
people would come and go flocking to see
the Elephant Man having spent the first
part of his life constantly hungry reys
was now being overfed every day hands
would come to his cage and force him to
eat Rich fatty foods denying him any
possibility of exercise eyes the broad
shoulders and strong legs that he had
developed while working at the circus
melted away under layers and layers of
fat his skin went gray and papery
folding and wrinkling in on itself
either from Fuller's magic or just from
a lack of sunlight whatever it was with
every passing day Rees Freeman steadily
became more and more hideous SCP 4409
was stuck in the circus for much of his
life eventually Herman Fuller moved on
and is currently being hunted by the SCP
Foundation when he did SCP 4409 was able
to bargain for its freedom from the
circus wandering from City to City never
sticking around for very long SCP 4409
begged for change at the side of the
road some people would feel sympathy
While most would feel horror at its
disfigurement from its years trapped in
a cage SCP 449 has developed severe
health issues including gout severe
obesity and metabolic syndrome while INF
Foundation custody it is fed a special
diet to counteract these conditions as
of yet the foundation has no way of
reversing what was done to Reese Freeman
in the tent in the 1800s as ree poses no
threat to the foundation he is allowed
to live with relative Freedom or at
least as much Freedom as a contained SCP
can earn his health condition severely
limits his Mobility around site 66 a low
security residential containment area
unable to walk even moderate distances
SCP 44 9 heavily relies on the use of a
cane and a heavyduty walker capable of
supporting up to 140 kg researchers
listen intently at his door waiting to
hear if he's ever going to play a sad
song on his trumpet but no sound ever
emerges except for his heavy breathing
and spluttering coughs it appears that
having spent decades locked in a small
cage a sedentary life is all he knows
now with every opportunity to exercise
read books and take up new hobbies as CP
4409 appears unable to engage with
anything other than sitting and staring
at the same spot on the wall every day
if an animal has spent its whole life
living in a zoo and finds in its old age
that one of the walls has fallen down
what use has it in taking a step outside
a giant monstrous crab like claw closes
around the throat of an unimaginably
huge eel-like Beast the beast's terrible
writhing tentacles wrap around and latch
onto the immense crustation and then the
high-intensity beams of gamma radiation
start flying all the while Legions of
skinless centaurs swim in the waters
around them relishing the violence and
in the middle a lone boat the scps
mither maned by a team of mobile task
force operatives that does all it can
just to survive there are those who
consider outer space to be the ultimate
achievement in Exploration the one place
that explorers have yet to chart and
understand however some of the murkiest
Mysteries in the universe are on our own
Planet deep down at the bottom of the
ocean 95% of the deep ocean remains
completely unexplored and the little
glimpses we have gotten paint a picture
of something truly alien giant squids
organisms that can breathe nitrogen
luminescent predatory fish and sharks as
old as the Earth itself even the SCP
Foundation is still struggling to fully
grasp the depth of the ocean and the
strange beings that dwell there one of
the most unusual aquatic findings in the
history of the foundation is that of SCP
3700 SCP 3700 refers to a circular area
in the North Sea with a diameter of 800
km the waters there are abnormally deep
for the region with the seafloor resting
at 5 km beneath the ocean's surface
there are two entities present in the
waters of SCP 3700 designated SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 interactions between these two
entities are responsible for the
anomalous changes to the meteorological
and geological conditions in the area
SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 always interact on the spring and
fall equinox es of Any Given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year seemingly at random
but what exactly are SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 aside from terrifying creatures of
the deep SCP 37001 is an arthropod
bearing an aesthetic resemblance to the
European Lobster only much much bigger
measuring 6 km in length the creature is
green with a mix of blue yellow pink and
red markings across the top of its
exoskeleton that bear the appearance of
a woman's face it has six prehensile
limbs four of which terminate in Claws
and eight legs the entities four eyes
are compound and orange attached to
stalks anyone who gets close enough to
observe the creature's carpas in detail
will notice scars cracks and small holes
indicating years and years of damage as
CP 37001 has several anomalous qualities
in addition to its size in a fight it is
able to strike with its appendages and
produce cavitation bubbles with a force
greater than several tons of Dynamite
two of the entities eyes are capable of
blasting concentrated gamma radiation at
a chosen Target the creature has the
ability to impact the weather around it
dispersing storms that impede its
ability to move with ease and can reach
speeds up to 100 km an hour in in spite
of its immense power SCP
37001 is not aggressive and tends to
ignore beings in its vicinity other than
SCP 3700 D2 speaking of SCP 3700 D2 it
is a 32 km long entity resembling a
pelican eel in all aspects except for
its massive size and the 13 appendages
that encircle the middle section of its
body these appendages which tuck inside
its body when not in use are similar to
the tentacles of an octopus complete
with suckers the majority of the
entity's body consists of a seny tail
terminating in a sharp point when its
mouth is open it is an estimated 3 kilm
deep its flesh is black and it has white
purple and red bioluminescent lines in
the shape of a man's face on either side
of its torso SCP 3700 d2's anomalous
properties include the ability to invoke
storms with the severity of category 5
hurricanes and the ability to produce
whirlpools that draw in any vessel
within 150 M so that it can rip them
apart it is also able to produce high
energy sound waves as well as blue fire
which it emits from its esophagus when
the two entities interact it results in
an epic struggle as each begins attempts
to destroy or subdue the other when one
is Victorious immediate changes to the
area follow when SCP 37001 winds the
storms and harsh weather in the area
will immediately calm and an era of
fertility and abundance will begin the
reproductive rates of fauna in the ocean
and on the Islands nearby increase
threefold and the crop yield doubles the
ocean itself becomes increasingly active
and the erosion rates of the
archipelago's shores increase fivefold
when SCP 3 700-2 winds however the
weather conditions become dangerous with
raging hurricanes rapidly fluctuating
temperatures and constantly changing
Storm fronts that cause destruction of
buildings and loss of life naturally
this renders any Ocean Travel in the
area extremely difficult or even
impossible aquatic food sources are
driven Away by harsh conditions and
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds water log soil and lack
of sunlight all the while SCP 37002
swims throughout the area praying on
unsuspecting ships and menacing the
coastline until SCP 37001 manifests to
challenge it again SCP
37002 will also regurgitate instances of
SCP
3456 though how or why this is possible
is unknown for those unfamiliar with SCP
3456 they are a group of hairless three-
toed horike creatures with thick
translucent skin and human torsos fused
to their backs they are most frequently
seen near sights of War terrorist
attacks and devastating natural
disasters direct observation of one of
these entities will draw their attention
to the Observer who the entity will then
stalk and capture before disappearing
due to their enormous size and ability
to anomalously manifest vest in their
home Waters SCP
37001 and 2 cannot be contained at a
foundation site instead their
containment is handled by Foundation
Naval task force Delta 7 Northern Storm
who Patrol the area in combination of
refurbished battleships destroyers
Cruisers and support craft additionally
measures have been taken to suppress
information about SCP 3700 among the
general population details about the
unusual depth of the water there have
been stricken from public texts and
scientific Publications SCP 37001 has
been implanted with donovian Hollow
projectors which disguise it as a pod of
humpback whales if SCP 37001 incounters
SCP
37002 Delta 7 May engage protocol winter
Maelstrom this consists of Destroyers
deploying Harpoon based anchors into SCP
3700 d2's head to hold it it in one
location next the vessels work together
to Target The Entity until SCP 37001 is
able to subdo it if this does not prove
effective and SCP
37002 cannot be contained then the task
force will Implement protocol tumult at
this point Naval and civilian crafts in
the area must be evacuated trade and
Ferry routes to the archipelagos must be
rerouted for at least 6 months there
will be constant aerial and Naval
engagement with SC p
37002 and constant monitoring for the
reappearance of SCP
37001 the behavior of SCP 37001 and SCP
37002 is largely very predictable with
one notable exception on March 20th 2017
a pair of SCP Foundation owned
battleships known as the mither and the
Teran arrived at a point between the
orne Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos
in the North Sea they were accompanied
by the usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 M away from the ship's
anchor points the water began to emit
intense bright rays of light for a
duration of 3 minutes at this point SCP
37001 appeared visible through the
surface of the water Delta 7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the entity
as the ships caught up to the entity it
raised two of its claws into the air
clicking them together in a friendly
greeting the Delta 7 ships followed the
entity along its usual swimming path for
30 minutes and during this time all was
peaceful but this peace did not endure
for long the tide began to change
literally as large black wall clouds
formed overhead the winds picked up and
the waves churned violently in response
SCP 37001 raised its claws overhead
waving them in a circular motion and
parting the clouds above it and Delta 7
but this effort took a lot out of the
creature and and after 30 seconds its
antenna began to droop and it lowered
its claws still the hole in the clouds
remained allowing a spot of sunshine to
break through and beam down on the
foundation vessels 600 M ahead the ocean
waters began to rage and froth spraying
foam and surf into the air SCP 37002
burst from beneath the surface its head
pointed upward it continued to rise
until the tops of its tentacles could be
seen just above the water then sto to
bend its torso and turn its head
horizontally its jaw unhinged exposing
rows upon rows of serrated teeth the
Beast let out a mighty Roar accompanied
by a stream of blue flame at the sight
of its rival SCP 37001 Dove beneath the
surface disappearing from view the scps
mither ordered the rest of the vessels
to engage protocol winter Maelstrom
Delta 7 scattered out from SCP 3700 d1's
point of submersion and all 13
destroyers fired their harpoons at SCP
3700 D2 embedding themselves in the
entity's head naturally this enraged the
creature and it began to Roar and whale
spinning its lower body vigorously
enough to generate a Whirlpool the
Cruisers opened fire with a combination
of L cannons and conventional Weaponry
in order to distract The Entity as the
Destroyers pulled their Harpoon lines TT
dragging its head in a continuous Circle
while this was taking place the
battleships got into position and
prepared to fire on the mither's Mark 3
2 1 fire the first broadside barrage
collided with SCP
37002 and it grunted in pain thrashing
back and forth before opening its mouth
and spewing an instance of SCP 3456 into
the water as soon as it hit the water
the eoin monster began to cut through at
a pace of 50 km an hour
making its way toward the Destroyers
particularly the scps selki the skki
attempted to retarget its weapons and
prevent the creature from reaching it
but the monster moved too quickly for
the skki to adjust the skki was lifted
out of the water by the creature as crew
members desperately clung to the
railings and their Weaponry as the crew
cowered and tried to fend off the
creature it reach for them trying to
pull them from the ship while the skki
was occupied SCP 37002 was able to
attack again again blasting another ship
with a stream of blue fire a loud crack
rang out from across the sea as the sky
dropped back into the water the SCP 3456
instance shrieking in pain SCP
3700-3 freed from its attack the skki
moved full steam ahead pulling the
Harpoon line TD again and dragging SCP
3700 D2 out of its path several silky
crew members were thrown overboard
during the struggle and as they
struggled to keep their heads above
water s SCP 37001 scooped them up
placing them onto the deck of a nearby
destroyer and out of Harm's Way with the
crew members rescued as SCP 3700 D1 set
its sights on its enemy swimming towards
the edge of the world pool and emitting
a luminescent glow from two of its eyes
the constant barrage of cannon fire on
SCP 37002 was beginning to take its toll
and the myther ordered the fleet to
quote brace for the killing blow as if
responding to the mither's call SCP
37001 shot several concentrated blasts
of gamma radiation at its foe leaving
large holes in the creature in their
wake SCP 37002 screamed flailing so hard
that it SNA spped the Harpoon lines and
created waves large enough to push the
vessels backward with its new found
Freedom SCP 37-2 impaled SCP 37001
through the midsection with its Barbed
tip of its tail lifting it up and out of
the water with the force of the blow SCP
37001 desperately tried to free itself
attacking the tail with its Club likee
limbs but the fight was in vain and
after a moment all movement stopped SCP
37001 was for at least the duration of
this manifestation dead SCP 37002 tossed
the corps into the water flinging it
past Delta 7 where it crashed into the
water and sank down Into the Depths
below at this point Delta 7 was ordered
to initiate protocol tumult the Delta 7
vessels turned away from SCP
37002 and prepared to evacuate the area
one of the ships the scps stron Beast
slowed behind the rest of the fleet
Fleet emitting concerning amounts of
smoke before coming to a stop meanwhile
the enraged and emboldened SCP 3700 D2
expanded the size of its Whirlpool
setting its sights on the retreating
ships and the weakened strawy Beast the
ship tried to flee but the engines were
completely shot and would not respond
the ship was caught in the whirlpool and
pulled against its will toward SCP 3700
D2 as the crew looked on in helpless
dread a tentacle Rose from from the deep
wrapping around the vessel and dragging
it toward the entity escaping Mall
suddenly SCP 37001 exploded from beneath
the surface of the water leaping between
the ship and SCP
37002 cutting the tentacle in half and
freeing the sty beast from its grip SCP
37002 shrieked before closing its jaws
and biting down on sccp
37001 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough Dam
damage to stop SCP 37002 from continuing
to produce its Whirlpool another
tentacle emerged from the water pulling
at SCP 3700 d1's legs and ripping them
from its body but SCP 37001 returned the
assault in kind bludgeoning SCP 3700 D2
with its club like limbs from inside of
its mouth all at once SCP 3700 d2's
lower jaw was torn out of place dropping
into the water with SCP 3700 -1 still
inside SCP 3700 D2 thrashed fuly growing
steadily weaker and weaker it released
one more stream of fire before
collapsing Delta 7 paused The Retreat
watching the scene for any sign of a
winner but after 5 minutes neither
entity had moved Delta 7 returned to the
side of the battle to investigate and
saw that neither entity was moving and
both appeared to be deceased shortly
after Delta 7 reached the area both
entities disappeared leaving a single
round unidentified object that sank
below the surface where SCP
37-1 had just been the wall clouds
overhead dispersed leaving standard Kumo
nimus clouds in their place the waters
themselves remained choppy unsure of how
to proceed the scps mither sent a radio
transmission to command ah this is Delta
7 to command we read you Delta 7 command
replied we have a bit of a situation go
ahead Delta 7
SCP
37001 and two are both down command was
silent for 10 seconds utterly baffled by
the information please repeat Delta 7
again the myther said SCP
37001 and 2 are both down command
ordered the mither to stand by 3 minutes
of radio silence later communication
resumed as they asked are either
entity's effects active ah negative
command is there any trace of either en
entity also negative it appears the
anomaly has been neutralized Delta 7 is
to return to base for debrief following
any recovery efforts with their next
steps clear Delta 7 attached the strawy
bees to several tugboats preparing to
pull the vessel to safety but there was
one more surprise waiting the scps
mither began picking up unusual levels
of gamma radiation as well as a sonar
contact at a depth of 3 km they called
command requesting permission to deploy
submers IES for exploration purposes 1
minute of Silence followed as the
command arrived at a decision request
denied return to base for debriefing and
so Delta 7 began to evacuate the area
once more steaming in the opposite
direction of the battle over the next 5
minutes CCTV cameras on the vessels
picked up an unusual sight as the gamma
radiation levels continued to increase
the ocean turbulence also worsened
tossing smaller vessels and nearly
causing them to capsize
then all of a sudden the water stilled
and four large yellow orbs appeared
below the surface approximately 300 M
from Delta 7 they lingered there for 2
minutes before Vanishing afterward a new
sonar contact was detected 5 km deep
directly beneath the task force command
we've lost the signal from the previous
contact and are no longer detecting
gamma radiation uh we're detecting new
contact 5 km deep large and metallic
after further Liberation command
responded Delta 7 you are authorized to
deploy submersibles for exploration
purposes we advise should SCP 37002
manifest exploration teams are to be
considered lost and you are to return to
base the consequences of this incident
as well as what else might be lurking
down in the depths beneath SCP 3700 are
still unknown picture this if you'll
excuse that foreshadowing pun you're at
your local City Mall in Ohio
a place that's never still every time
you go there no matter what time of day
or day of the week it's always full of
people all bustling about shopping
eating dashing past one another maybe
presumably like everyone else you came
in to get some specific item or you
might just be browsing heck you could be
there for a casual date or to grab a
bite to eat at the food court that's
when you remember you need to have your
picture taken it could be that your
passport is about to expire or your
driver's license hasn't been updated
since you moved whatever the reason
lucky for you there's a photo booth
right here in the mall take your own
photo boasts the sign on the outside of
the cramped cubicle a list of
instructions below describing just how
quick and easy the process is you take a
look at the price list feed the right
amount of money into the slot and take a
seat inside pulling the curtain closed
you straighten your back look directly
into the lens a short countdown appears
on the screen 3 2 1 a flash bursts from
the bulb above the lens filling the
booth and leaving those white spots
floating in your vision for a few
moments you head back out of the cubicle
waiting to pick up the glossy paper with
your photos on it as it starts rapidly
printing them off you wanted a 2X two
four total pictures of your face but
then as it finishes Printing and you
inspect the pictures turning the paper
in your hands you're met with a surprise
and unnerving one to say the least
the pictures don't show your face in
fact it barely looks like a human face
at all it has your clothes and your hair
but the whole image has been warped not
just out of focus but completely
disproportional annoyed that you spend
your money only to receive a highly
distorted image you wander off to find
another Booth throwing the unusable
picture in the nearest trash can now
sure you might write off something like
that as just an odd occurrence a freak
of Technology caused by faulty machinery
in desperate need of repair but what you
don't know in fact you won't even
realize until it's too late is what
really just happened when you sat down
and that flash went off taking your
picture and printing it off as a warped
unrecognizable mess something was born
located at the end of a series of long
winding concrete stairs and kept out of
sight behind doors marked keep out and
staff only is a lower level of the mall
hidden in this dark off-limits area that
no member of the public public is
permitted to access there is a service
door somewhere in the southwest corner
of the third sub basement just taking a
look at it you could easily imagine
nothing at all interesting behind it
like a power generator or a storage room
but if you were to push it open and
Venture inside you'd stumble upon
something you would never have expected
in your wildest dreams or more
accurately your most disturbing
nightmares beyond that service door is a
cavern hardly the first thing you'd
assume to be be secreted away underneath
a city shopping mall although if you're
into cave jumping it would be ill
advised to take a spelunking Adventure
down there the entire Cavern isn't
actually part of our world it's an
extradimensional space think of it as
its own little pocket universe that has
somehow become connected to ours and can
now be accessed through this doorway if
it helps you can even picture our
universe as a big soap bubble with a
slightly smaller bubble attached to it
in actuality it's infinitely more
complicated and looks nothing like two
bubbles of different sizes but like we
said if it helps to picture it that way
then go right ahead if you were brave
enough or naive enough to venture deeper
into this cave and not to be put off by
its walls that look like they've been
carved from Pure Limestone then you
would have had to watch your step to
avoid a nasty fall within the large cave
space is a deep dark pit a rocky conduit
in the ground seemingly leading down
into the Earth but taking a closer look
the walls of this pit aren't made of
rock they don't even match the Limestone
that the rest of the cavernous room
looks to be cut from the surface of the
pit is coated in a slimy substance
closer to something biological coming
from a living thing rather than being
carved out of rock depending on your
familiarity with the texture you might
even say this substance is not all that
far off from the appearance and feel of
human fat tissue although you probably
shouldn't reach in to try and touch it
for yourself least of because the walls
of the pit are constantly secreting a
corrosive substance like acid that could
easily break down your body by its
molecules painfully burning you until
you melted down into soup but there's
something else down there lots of
something as a matter of fact in the
moment you took that photo sitting in
the safety of the booth in the mall
above a new something found itself Born
Into the pit it looks almost exactly
like you but its face is all wrong you
you could even say distorted like a
photograph that didn't quite come out
right the abnormalities in its face
could take the form of lacerations cuts
and open wounds or bloody welts like
looking in a mirror at a twisted injured
version of yourself or this imperfect
copy might have growth bulging out from
its head covering its facial features to
make it virtually unrecognizable as a
clone of you then again maybe it'll just
come out missing everything no eyes
mouth nose just a blank expressionless
mask on a body otherwise identical to
yours and what does this thing this
clone do now that it finds itself in a
pit filled with other writhing imperfect
copies of everyone that's ever sat to
have their picture taken in that photo
booth well what would you do you would
try to get out as quickly as possible
and that's what it will start doing
while you're going about the rest of
your day maybe stopping off at a few
stores in the mall or complaining to the
customer service staff laugh about that
faulty photo booth it's already started
climbing its fingernails are digging
into that fleshy tissue that coats the
walls of the pit as the copy drags its
imperfect body upwards crawling over the
others around it that are trying to do
the exact same there's no telling just
how many of them are down there how many
misshapen heads and deformed faces your
clone has had to barge past and climb
over as they all pile deep down within
their hole in the ground and what's the
worst part of all this
it's not just the climb the fact that
your copy has to fight its way out of
the pit making the near impossible
Ascent to make it to the surface no the
worst part is that you have no idea it's
happening you're completely oblivious
that a distorted clone of you is raking
its nails against walls of fat tissue
clambering up from underneath the ground
and even more so you have no idea what
it wants to do when it gets free and
finds you the SCP Foundation has long
since been keeping an eye on the anomaly
that they themselves have designated as
SCP 715 given that the photo booth
itself was connected to the
extradimensional space buried deep below
the mall removing it isn't really an
option sure they could have easily have
cordoned it off and put up signs saying
the booth was out of order to deter
members of the public from trying to use
it but this was the SCP Foundation after
all they needed to run tests figure out
exactly what this anomaly did and how it
ticked Gerald Patton had been a rising
star at the foundation a promising
researcher who had long been proving his
medal since he first became part of the
organization for a Time the higher-ups
at the foundation had planned to attach
the researcher to the SCP 2090 project
studying a basketball player who somehow
gained anomalous Powers however hearing
about the photo booth in the Ohio City
Mall he turned down this request to
instead join the team researching SCP
7115 certain highlevel staff of the SCP
Foundation noted this to be strange
Patton had never turned down a promotion
before as the SCP 2090 project would
have offered him better pay and more
vacation time in order to observe the
photo booth closely without alerting the
public to their presence Foundation
staff on site were disguised to blend in
with civilians and some posed as retail
staff employed at the mall come closing
time once everyone else that worked
there or who had been shopping
throughout the day had finally left the
foundation researchers were free to run
their tests and investigate the
anomalous photo booth it was the night
of a routine Sweep All staff members on
site were required to test the
surrounding area for reality warping
anomalies The Sweep was mandatory for
the entire team assigned to SCP 7115 yet
quite unusually researcher Paton didn't
report in for the procedure the high-ups
at the foundation decided to let this
indiscretion slide though after all
there were a lot of personnel involved
in the process so patent was let off the
hook in fact the few disparities and
patents behavior only became more
apparent when Dr Agatha wri began to
more closely collate and process the
files and information on the Personnel
on site she was the research head on the
SCP 715 project and quickly noticed a
few things that didn't add up about
researcher Gerald Patton his rejection
of the offer to join the SCP 2090
project and refusal to attend a routine
reality bending anomaly sweep might have
seemed like unrelated incidents at first
but both would have brought the
researcher into contact with technology
that the foundation used specifically to
detect any distortions to reality if he
had taken the promotion or been present
for the sweep he too would have been
within the scope of this specialized
detection equipment yet both times he
managed to avoid being put in such a
position what the hell was patent hiding
and what would show up if a detector was
pointed at him Dr Wes was growing ever
more suspicious of researcher patent and
his behavior however it was when she
learned he had secretly tested the photo
booth himself that she decided to take
matters into her own hands in order to
get to the bottom of what Gerald was up
to she had to mull it over and think
about things cautiously she couldn't
confront him directly at least not yet
even the evidence she already had that
Patton had seemingly twice avoided
situations involving the use of reality
Distortion detection equipment wasn't
enough to prove for certain he was
hiding something both instances could
have been caused by something completely
unrelated Gerald could have rejected his
promotion purely because he was more
interested in SCP 715 than joining the
SCP 2090 project and even Foundation
Personnel needed sick days or skipped
work because of a hangover without
telling anyone which could explain why
he was absent during the sweep of the
mall but Agatha wasn't convinced it felt
like the two instances lined up too
closely they felt far too similar to be
an utterly random coincidence even if
Gerald wasn't up to anything dangerous
the only way to know for sure was to
observe him but without drawing
attention to it he deny anything act
completely differently maybe even flat
out lie if he knew someone was listening
or watching Agatha was forced to think
in a way that was as calculated as she
was certain Gerald had been his quarters
were located in a secluded part of the
sub basement a level above where the
fleshy pit could be found almost all the
foundation Personnel assigned to SCP 715
Le somewhere on site their presence
there masked from the ordinary Mall
employees taking care not to be detected
they had installed doors with a key card
system meaning only members of their own
staff could access the living quarters
under the mall if any civilians happened
to stumble upon the foundation and
discover them then all it took was the
careful application of amnestics to
ensure that they wouldn't remember a
thing beeping her key card at the door
Agatha slipped into the living area it
mostly consisted of a narrow Corridor
with rows of doors doors on either side
behind each one was a cramped room each
only big enough for one person a bunk to
sleep in and a sink with a mirror above
it Gerald's room was the furthest from
the entrance right down at the end of
the corridor as far from everyone else
as he could get although it also meant
if he came back from testing early then
he'd be more likely to catch Agatha
leaving his room and walking back along
the road it would be hard to come up
with an excuse as to what she was doing
anywhere near his quarters especially as
her room was right behind the very first
door right next to the entrance all this
was rushing through Dr W's mind as she
squeezed into Patton's room in actual
fact the Interior Space of them was so
limited that they were even smaller than
most ship cabins her hand had been
clasped around the handle of a metal
case which she sat down on Gerald's
empty bed unclasping the clips that held
it closed Agatha opened up the case and
took out what was held inside the inner
layer of protective foam it was the
Fullman breaker anomalous optic IC
enhancement device a piece of the
specialized apparatus that Foundation
researchers use to record and identify
any person or object that might be
exhibiting anomalous properties it
utilized state-of-the-art Optical
enhancement technology and could be used
to detect whether a subject was causing
any Distortion to the reality around it
by accessing visual spectrums that were
normally imperceivable to the naked
human eye or sometimes even unobservable
in this Dimension Agatha looked around
the tiny cabin given The Limited space
she was also short on options as to
where she could hide the device without
it being easily noticed it was also
imperative that researcher Patton had no
idea he was under observation Dr Wes
looked over to the sink in the corner
the mirror just above it sure it was a
tactic taken straight out of the big
book of spy novel cliches but it would
work the advanced Spectrum capabilities
of the optical enhancement device would
be able to record patent through the
glass luckily the entire living quarters
had been pretty hastily built which
meant it took little effort for Agatha
to loosen the screws holding the mirror
in place but that's when she heard the
distinctive beep of the door to the
living quarters followed by the gradual
footsteps getting closer and closer it
might not have been Gerald but there was
also an equal chance that it could have
been acting as fast as she could Agatha
placed the optical enhancement device on
the wall and covered it with the mirror
frantically trying to screw it back into
place as quick as she could the echoing
noise of someone approaching sounded as
if they were almost right outside the
cabin door by the time Dr wries had
tightened the screws enough to keep the
mirror in place giving a quick final
scan of the room making sure nothing
looked too conspicuous she grabbed the
empty case and smoothed out the duvet
where it had been laying leaving no
Trace that she had ever been there her
heart already racing it almost exploded
right out of her chest as she slipped
back out of the door to Patton's cabin
only to see him walking down the narrow
Corridor directly towards his room
towards her uh Dr rights Gerald greeted
with a stag smile though the suspicion
on his face was so unmistakable that it
could have probably shown up clearly on
camera something I can help you with
Patton Agatha gave a polite nod back to
the researcher lifting the case behind
her back the one upside of the tight
Corridor was that Patton was so close to
her he couldn't see what she was hiding
the obvious downside being he might be
close enough to clock Dr wri's suspicion
of him did you need something Patton
chuckled sorry it's just what were
youing doing in my quarters her heart
was still racing desperately trying to
form a plausible excuse somewhere in her
mind Agatha's free hand reached into her
pocket something brushing against her
fingertips would have to do you drop
this she exclaimed pulling out a $20
bill and handing it to Gerald a small
price to pay to keep her subterfuge
earlier on in the mall near SCP 715 I
saw it fall out of your pocket I had
other matters to attend to down at
anyway I wanted to make sure you got it
back oh thank you Gerald blinked in
Surprise taking the money as she
squeezed past him and walked out of the
living quarters Agatha could barely stop
her hands from shaking although those
Tremors of nures would have to become
the trembling of absolute horror when
she saw the footage that the optical
enhancement device collected Patton was
one of the creatures from the pit it
didn't seem possible he didn't even have
clearance to know about the pit and any
of the Clones or SC cp715 dasas that
managed to claw their way up to the
surface were immediately terminated by
on-site security the instances becoming
known as SCP 715 BS if they made it that
far yet somehow Patton or whatever he
really was had made it through
undetected but that was far from the
worst Discovery Dr Wes would make she
used a number of the same anomalous
Optical enhancement devices to observe
the SCP 7158 creatures within the pit
only to find that she and the other
researchers had made a grave mistake the
SCP 75- a they were all human
what the foundation had initially
thought were the distorted imperfect
clone copies of everyone who had used
the SCP 715 photo booth were actually
The Originals they had been trying to
climb back up because they wanted to
come home their place is taken by SCP
715 DBS but none of those people now
Twisted disfigured and unrecognizable
were able to explain to the foundation
who they were and they'd been shot left
to fall back into the pit and die acting
fast Dr Wes updated the classification
of SCP 715 to ker although This was
later rescinded back too safe the
creature that looked like researcher
patent was apprehended and brought in
for interrogation after learning the
truth behind SCP 715 the photo booth was
secured and locked up permanently but as
of now the project investigating SCP 715
has been put on hold no one at the
foundation wants to admit their mistake
that they now have an exra dimensional
pit full of innocent distorted people or
that they have no idea where all their
body swapped counterparts are now go and
check out SCP 1733 season opener for
another tale of another anomaly caught
on film this time it's a basketball game
that you won't be able to stop watching
or if you'd rather further your
investigation into some more paranormal
photography then we've got just the
video for you SCP 978 the desire camera